before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys if you want to be a
part of the chat the second half of the
stream sign up for our memberships there
are three tiers so there's a five dollar
tier that way you can be a part of the
chat there is a 10 tier you get access
to our two Vlogs that are on the um that
are on members only and you also get
access to our Discord and there is a
another there's I don't know what the
third tier is but you get to connect
with us on social media and the third
tier so
today we have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age
your relationship status and tell me a
fun fact about you
so you're starting with you
okay hi everyone I'm Yasmin I'm 32 and
I'm engaged and a fun fact about oh
you're engaged yay I love love thank you
um a fun fact
um
oh
I would say I'm the
the fun out of the crowd I like to you
know drop some gems also some you know
um
jokes here and there and just be myself
really that's what I do cool
daily 26 what was the third day your
relationship status had a fun fact
teacher it's fun make sure it's fun
I lost my virginity in a log
there you go that's not I'm not gonna
lie that's not what I meant but okay
okay
so I'm Tiffany I'm 29 years old
um I'm single and I thought the only
thing I can think of right now I don't
know why this has come to me but the fun
fact about me is I tried out pole
dancing once and I tried out doing a
show in front of families and friends
and then like completely messed up the
whole routine
um but just smiled through it anyway but
it was a bit promote but laughs I'm
happy
luckily no nip slip but I had this cute
little headband on and it just like
there was one where I went to like swish
my head the thing just flew off and it
was terrible yeah it was funny
um yeah I'm peace over uh 31.
um I'm single
fun fact about me is make it super fun
uh I don't know uh but I've uh I'll say
I've never broken a bone in my body
that's a fact I don't know if it's fun
but that's a fun one
okay guys so also quick thing like the
video how many people are in the chat
right now
we got 230 230 people we need a hundred
likes at least y'all a like is free
subscribe to the channel okay if you've
seen two or more of these lives and you
don't subscribe we have beef okay beef
also also all super chats will be read
so if you have something that you just
really want to get off your mind get off
your plate tell the panel
Um send a Super Chat and we will read it
you already know we are saving money for
a what camera get us a camera guys we're
aiming to get it at the end of this
month so all donations are going towards
getting issue camera and also um other
camera angles hopefully too we can buy a
couple
so today's topic is our modern women
children and what inspired this is I
used to watch a lot of like pickup
videos
um
like
um what's that guy's name alpha male
strategies I used to do reactions to him
I used to do just like guys in the
pickup and like relationship sort of
game and one
thing that a lot of either dating
coaches or pickup coaches said was to
treat women like children
because they're so emotional that you
have to like act like they're children
and I wanted to know men's point of view
have you heard that before
um
I've never heard that before
but I think it look it happens in a lot
of Apple in application so in terms of
if you were to break to a lady that
she's she's got a fat you'd have to
break it in bite side terms you wouldn't
be able to tell her the realness so
you'd have to assume like a child how
the child reacts if you were to tell
them something of that magnitude but
really if you just say to your boy like
when I gained weight my boy just laughed
at me he said grab my belly and said
that what happened
so you almost have to cuddle women a
little bit yeah you have to do talking
like you know when you're it's obviously
you're a different system but the
English people like GCSE waffle is like
I'm not saying that but if you know just
slightly if you just you know and you
just have to turn it around and just
talk women's
ears
me as well I've never heard of that term
but
in life you you kind of notice these
kind of things because obviously girls
want to get looked after and you know
they're emotional and stuff like that
and as you said you have to kind of like
give them the truth in bite size so
because obviously they can't really
handle the whole truth leading on that
but what you're saying about being
looked after
a lot of modern women compared to Old
School women they're actually looking
for a father so they're looking to be
treated like a princess then rather than
being treated like a queen so in terms
of that's probably what Pick Up Artist
means and a lot of women want sweet
things which is something okay let's say
they'd want you to
come back when they come back from work
for you to wait up for them for crazy
hours that's something your father would
do as your partner your partner you have
other things to be dealing with rather
than to be holding your hand through
every single incidence but that probably
leads back to the emergence of the
single parent home and looking for that
Father Figure what do you guys think
um I I do think that with women we we uh
we have that emotion emotional side
sometimes and sometimes people feel they
might have to tiptoe around things but I
haven't actually heard that myself
actually but overall I do believe um
that women do have those those traits as
well what about you yeah I think we are
emotional as women but the the to
compare us against like talking to us
like children it's like what what is
meant by that like what is meant by
talking to us like children because when
I imagine someone talking to a child
it's almost like you know putting on
this putting on this facade or like
high-pitched voice and excited and being
like no no no you know like hi little
baby AI whereas I think we do wait do
women
says when do like what do we really need
to be communicated I think it's not that
um it's not talking to you as children
like as in putting on a high-pitched
voice but it's more in the sense of like
when you're talking to a child you have
to kind of you know there's a saying
that I don't know what film it was some
guy will say oh tell me like I'm six
years old so that I can understand so
it's like when you want to talk to it
like when you have to talk to a child
you have to tell them things in a
certain way so that they understand you
won't talk to a child the same way that
you'll talk to a grown adult but with
women like you won't necessarily talk to
them like a kid like a little baby but
you'll talk to them you won't you will
talk to them in a manner where
you're kind of like beating around the
bush just so that they can understand
what you're saying and not and so that
they don't you know take it to one
extreme or another extreme and sometimes
you will Pander to them and change your
voice like you know that just that dress
looks horrible and it looks terrible but
you'll just say ah you know what maybe
it's not the day for this maybe the Sun
the way the lighting is not but it looks
[ __ ] and that's the way you talk to a
child you know what I think of what I
think of like that you have to talk to
women like children if I if I say on a
show I say you know women like men with
money the men don't go around and say
well it's not all all women like men
with money or like like guys don't do
that but if a girl if I say hey men
prefer thin women there's always someone
that's like well but not all men like
thin women and it's almost like talking
like pulling teeth sometimes or even
like trying to have a discussion about
like the abortion debate right someone
always brings up grape
always even though it's less than one
percent of abortions and so it's like I
it's really hard to have conversations
with women without them bringing up the
exception to the rule
yeah that makes right that makes com but
then but again again you're like looking
at things from like all different
perspectives if you're saying that
there's that most women are be you need
to talk to most women like children then
obviously that's still an argument to an
exception not the rule oh no I mean like
most I'd say that's more the rule like
like I talk to women every day you know
and like I'm not saying there's not
reasonable women that you can have
conversations with I meet them all the
time but I'd say like there's a
substantial percentage of women that I I
can't have a conversation with them
without them bringing up some exception
but man like if I bring that up like
they're pretty like they don't argue
with me when I say women like guys with
money or tall guys they're not like
Daley's not here saying like but but you
know even though we even though it's
very well even though we understand that
not every single woman might you know
love a man with money some women are
content you know whoever they have we
get that but the overwhelming majority
of women are hypergamous so we have
after that acknowledge that fact and um
but when it's when it's like when you're
talking to a woman as she said when
she's talking about grape or something
like that or when she's talking about
abortion you know women will bring up oh
yeah but there's grape you know and we
understand that there's grapes no one's
arguing that there's there's no grip but
it's that when you bring up those like
those like things that are basically
insignificant in terms of like the 100
of things like it's you know it's kind
of like off putting of the conversation
you're taking things to the extreme kind
of thing do you think that's because
they want to justify the reason or is it
do you think it's a personal aspect
they're coming from It's Always personal
I feel like shows like this and other
shows it's like we talk abstract so for
example when I talk about my pod we talk
about
what ideal male is like so we talk about
the guy has money his respect to much
men women love him good looking etc etc
I'm five foot nine in my message I don't
pick and choose and take height out of
it all because I'm small objectively
that's the truth but then when if you
were to go to like a chubby chaser
podcast where there's loads of big
things they'll start they'll change the
message and say oh you know what some
men like real women and the reality is
if your BMI is a cricket score most men
aren't going to like you
all right
but like so it's almost like you're
coddling girls the same way you coddle
children when you tell them like Santa's
real more like or or like you know when
you you kind of
make some harsh realities softer because
they don't really need to know the truth
it's almost like how women are nowadays
but I find it dangerous I find it
negligent like I find like do you ever
find that when you chat to your closest
friend you can tell them the real truth
because they're not going to get upset
but it comes from a good place but I
thought even when I look at like my
female friends Dynamics they can't be
entirely honest with each other because
they're mummy cuddling each other which
is a dangerous place to be because
really and truly you should be cut
throat and get to the point in order to
get the best for them do you not think
there's more and more women that are
starting to do that though even with
their friends like starting to become
like more honest more cut through
there's more of like this rise of women
who are looking for that straightforward
honesty as opposed to this
baby talk I think
um I think they
they want to but I don't think they
really want to because it's like it's
like you you would say that yeah the
girls want the truth and you know the
hard truth the cold truth and whatnot
but when when they hear the truth they
argue it but do you understand it's like
for example if I say yeah
um if you say yeah as Pearl said if you
say uh girls like men with money you
know they'll argue it back and won't be
like no no not all girls not all girls
and all you know so it's like they do
want the truth but
they don't they can't they're not really
capable of handling the truth so and I
think a great sorry a great example
would be yesterday's show where we had
three women and we tried to explain to
them that when women get to a certain
age and have kids
their value goes down and they were
adamant that that isn't the case they
could date whoever they want and where
we try to then compartmentalize it to
try and go and beat around the bush so
it wasn't as direct to be like all right
you're not gonna get the guy you want to
commit to you they still couldn't
comprehend what we were saying or
understand what we were saying so but
like if you say to a guy you need to
make more money before you can really
get a girl you're dead broke like who's
gonna date you
most guys will agree do you think that
maybe like the reason why that is is
because historically women have been
suppressed from being speaking for
themselves and being honest like for
themselves
but how are they suppressed in not I
guess
so we've got like social conditions that
have these we have these social
conditions right that have
put certain belief systems in place that
have unconsciously maybe created this
idea that women are you know if they
speak up or if they say something then
it's out of place it's not their place
to say something and I think that
unconscious belief that has kind of
formed over the time is maybe still at
least um so I just don't understand
specifically like what like and when and
where okay
um so like because I think there are
powerful women in history yeah like yeah
and so um I mean typically like men
built the institution so you're not
gonna see like what why would why would
you bring women into an institution that
like men build and you still see women
throughout history that get to be a part
of those institutions even though they
didn't build them yeah they do and I
think you know like how how we speak
about you know you've got you know
you've got people who are the exception
not the rule I think even in that time
where you know you have certain women
who have been the exception and not the
rule even in in that time but I think
for the majority now it depends it
really depends because even okay you
know Jamestown like because I'm from the
US so I'm just going to use a U.S
example you're like Jamestown the the
original men that were like taken for
Jamestown were kidnapped so it was
Jamestown oh sorry sorry that's the
first like um U.S colony and so they
were they were literally kidnapped and
like sent to the U.S where where they
tried to do it with women and they
wouldn't let them because like they're
like whatever men are expendable that's
how they felt and so it just depends
like certain men did have a lot of power
but like women were definitely at a
higher place in society than some men I
guess that makes that does make sense
because as women we are without women
you can you can't grow the population
and for most humans our for most humans
we see that
that our general life cycle is that you
grow up you have you work and you then
you have kids and then your parents have
a sense of purpose that they've had
grandchildren and you've LED down the
line so it makes sense protect women for
right but I'm saying I'm saying like I
wouldn't necessarily say that women by
and large throughout history were like
silenced
and like didn't have a voice you know I
would yeah I think because his because
history has shown that there are women
who have spoken up who haven't been
silent as well so you know you can't
dispute you can't dispute that but so
like I said those women are the
exception of the rule and it's like we
we live like we have this fundamental
you could also say the men that were
speaking up were also the exception not
the rule
because like throughout history like a
large portion of men didn't even
reproduce so I'm saying like even the
men that did speak up you could say they
were more of the exception yeah but then
I think in in history you have that
representation that men have like even
where we're saying like men have to kind
of break certain things down and they
have to be that they have to be that
person in that relationship that's
almost kind of well women needed
protection like they can't help like men
are stronger physically yeah so they
have to lead because like historically
women yeah like they would they needed
protection and I think and I think this
day and age like especially like the
modern era like
people forget that um the world wasn't
civilized you understand oh the world
only became civilized like after World
War II maybe like and uh before then
it was like everyone knew their their
role in society everyone like the men
knew there was Expendable they knew they
had to go to war if you know the
government called upon it you know do
you understand so and I think because
we've lived in a civilized like Society
for so long I think people just people
start to forget how
uncivilized the world actually was and
how violent the world actually was like
I was looking at um I was talking to my
boy about this and I was like and we'll
talk about how violent London is and
it's like and it's just kids
the kids are the violent ones and it's
these little boys these little 13 year
old kids and then it got me thinking it
was like like imagine like the growth
imagine those grown-ass Men actually
doing this now like and like the world
would be won't be safe for anyone do you
understand and it's like it's men that
civilized other men for and I think they
symbolize other men for the women do you
understand so that women can you know
sit in places like this and you know
have a job with air conditioning in the
room and stuff like that could you get
me like so it's like when you when when
you get into that kind of situation
where I think women start to forget that
ill this world was really not civilized
and you know the men have actually
civilized this world and they've given
us a place where we can actually talk to
understand where we can actually speak
our mind so because even historically
how can we say we were oppressed or we
don't have to fight in Wars
but I think we yeah remain we may not
have physically have to fight in Wars I
think you know at the end of the day men
do have more physical strength than
women that's a fact there's no doubt
about that and I think because of that
it's create it's so certain Dynamics so
for example you know when what you said
about security we know we associate
Security with physical security you know
physical safety you know if if we're
being attacked by something it's it's
our physical strength that is going to
protect us from it if we're going to eat
then it's the physical physical act of
eating that's going to protect us from
it so we've always just from that
Natural Instinct we've always kind of
had that superiority of physical traits
being Superior because it's yeah
benefits in our survival as human beings
right but I'm I'm still saying like then
we aren't a pro like we weren't even
oppressed historically I would say
because we got the benefit of having men
to protect us
where they had to go off and do it like
we're not entitled to that just for
existing like we got we were we got the
benefit of that you know yeah and it's a
protection from other men I think men
got the benefit too because if men were
if men didn't men are men have this
strength which is their physical
strength and within that Dynamic they're
able to
you know protect women because women are
the means to the rest of the rest of the
world means the rest of life it means
the rest of the population growing so
that you know that Dynamic makes a lot
more sense
especially then but now it's like we
live in a we live in a day and age where
things are so much more complex we're
not just Instinct we're not we obviously
we're still there is element of there
but things are a lot more complex so you
know and I think this is where
our beliefs and so you said it worked
for the benefit of man like how
because because because
as men as well they want to grow they
want to have they want to expand they
want to you know they want to have that
Legacy of having a child and then being
able to teach that child how to be great
and be there no but I'm talking about
like like historic like 360
000 to or there's 500 000 500 000 deaths
just in like the I mean I'm from the US
so I'm just using like in the Civil War
like how was that a benefit because
without because because the men can
because with that more men can die you
only need one man to like breed multiple
women you don't need multiple men to
breed to have
you know that that instinctual right but
I'm saying it like again it goes back to
it's a small percentage of men that get
the benefit the majority of men did not
reproduce historically and and that's
all the same today but it worked out
better for us in the long run because
we're you know at the end of the day for
women yeah for women but for men as well
because men are no no it's not like
we're we're you know I know we have more
women than men sorry but it's like you
know men
are here they exist they still make an
impact they're still no but like the but
it goes back to
it benefit it benefited all women and it
benefited a small percentage of men it
didn't benefit all men
so like a lot of times we look at this
like history in a revisionist way where
we forget about all the men that died to
get us to where we are when and they
didn't a lot of them didn't even get to
reproduce yeah they didn't and so like
when you're saying it benefited men
that's not accurate wait didn't benefit
obviously all men because the majority
yeah but it obviously but in terms of
how we
continue as a human race I think it's
the species yeah I mean as a species it
works right there but if you if you take
a micro example it's like
people talk about how being a [ __ ] way
will benefit men but only benefits a
selector of men because say if you take
a classroom those five men are going
through all those women and breaking all
their hearts and they're all getting a
piece and they're complaining that their
heart's been broken but what about the
20 other guys in the classroom that have
just been sitting there watching World
of Warcraft and tugging their meat with
no play for the whole of their school
career but everyone forgets about them
because they're not significant so
that's just a micro example to show
there's only a few men that actually
benefit of it so that's really a
minority so if you're it's purely
capitalist in the sense of if you can
Excel and be an elite at it then yeah of
course you benefit so like Drake and
[ __ ] Brad Pitt they have a great life
but what about Mr Average Joe who's
quite again no play for the rest of his
life
all those women and that's the that's
the society that we live in today you
know it's literally the same as as
opposed say the same as historically
only a small percentage of men benefited
back then and only a small percentage of
men are benefiting now because if you
ask 100 of women what they want in the
men to describe 20 of men sometimes it's
even less to understand so it's like you
like like what girls want
is the top percent of the man
and that leaves you know the 80 of men
with nothing but then how do you how do
you know that statement to be true
because you're saying like you're
referring to 100 of women because you
have dating app data or women can be
more honest than ever oh yeah they can
and so like some 20 is generous honestly
some Studies have it at five percent I
say 20 like honestly to be generous but
it's typically a smaller and smaller
percentage
yeah because I was thinking about it the
other day I was like a lot of women say
that they want you know
a lot of guys they want a guy you know
six figures six foot six pack you know
the six six eight like the one that and
um
and the average average person in the UK
makes that 38 Grand a year I think it's
30k bro 30k yeah that's just London fake
here do you understand so it's like so
it's like where's this six figure guy
gonna come from but that's what women
want though that's what women want so
it's like the guy that's not making that
six figure
it's not he has to kind of like step on
eggshells especially when she when he's
around a kind of woman that he kind of
wants and whatnot because if he if he
flips up we're in a generation now where
women think feel like they can do better
do you understand you're making 38 Grand
a year and there's this guy with a blue
check in my DMs there's this guy with a
blue check in my DMs so if you try it I
can Skip and go to that guy so it's like
it's still the same as as it was back in
the day but now it's just modern now
it's just different do you understand
now you can see the high value men you
know they got blue text on their
Instagram so it's like it's just it's
the same as it was back in the day it's
just different so I'm gonna show you
guys
um daily you've already seen this
um I don't have the ish I know you're
pulling up the chart but I don't
I don't have it for you so I'm just
going to show it to them but it's um
actually let me see if I can wait which
shot is this the same one I showed you
the other day when you look at because
you're saying that it's different now
than it was back in the day right or
like you're saying it's um it's the same
as it was but so something that oh this
shocked me this is the divorce rate in
oral contraceptive use
but you want me to send this dish can
you yeah yeah yeah that's crazy
so it's exactly the same yeah
so can you send it to Paul please yes I
don't know
about to power not to me yeah Instagram
yeah yeah
sorry gone
um so they're gonna show it to you he's
going to show it to you in the chat in a
second but it's almost like when you
take away the consequences for women
they act like children
because they took away the consequence
of getting pregnant so what happened
they started leaving their husbands and
they said okay you get the ability to
sleep with whoever you want and not get
pregnant they said
screw this beta I'm married to for 20
years
they're modern women children
I think to like okay so like he was
saying
right I think yesterday as well this
chart came up with the contraception and
I think it's got a lot to do with with
choice I think
you know back in the day maybe as women
we didn't feel like we had the option to
you know to get [ __ ] down by like
whoever yeah
[Laughter]
like now
of this power of this choice that we've
never really had before like yeah women
have more Choice than ever in their life
not just with dating but with career
options with life options like now
there's all these multiple routes that
you don't even have to have kids if you
don't want to like there's so much
choice in how you live your life where
previously
that has been
I I don't know whether to use word
dictated or Guided by men right because
that we lived in like I believe we've
lived in a man's world like you said all
these systems are created by men and I
think as well when we go back to like
the world what like the world war I'm
not happening you know women fair enough
men were at the front line but there was
women behind the scenes they had to get
involved and I think they had to step up
and show up and I think actually that
showed men a whole new light to women in
terms of what women are capable of doing
what do you which were
yeah like yeah so like you know like
you're saying when they they worked in
factories yeah exactly so and then that
gave women even more choice right
because now we are aware that women are
capable of doing things like women are
capable of like doing tasks that are
useful or even more useful not just not
just to be in a family house I'd have
babies and well I don't I don't think it
was historically that they couldn't I
think a lot of women it was more
necessary because again there is a
consequence of birth like getting
pregnant yeah and like so I don't think
it was necessarily that they couldn't do
it I mean
I can't remember what Empire it was but
like there was a lot of women that owned
business even like before the US was
formed yeah but like if you're looking
if you if you're looking at this kind of
a whole cultural I don't even call it
like a cultural shift in like and how
the women have women's status has
evolved and
but I I think I think that's incorrect
though because again women's status was
above most men so again we always look
at like the like modern day women have
this ideology that like we were
oppressed throughout history and it's
just not true but I still think that
doesn't dispute the fact that we we have
we things happen enough has happened
over the years like disruptive things
have happened that have given light to
the fact that women are have way more
Choice it perceived or like aware of
choices more now than what they were
which is obviously but technology has
advanced yeah so so I I again I don't
think it's like we were oppressed ever
like technology has just Advanced but I
think then you've got to ask yourself
like
what is it then to to to to be oppressed
or what is it to what does it even mean
to be oppressed like for women that lack
of choice was oppression or the lack of
knowing of that choice was oppression
what lack of choice in terms of compared
to what we have now in terms of the fact
that we have the pill and we're able to
go and expl you know we're able to have
options with men and dating and get you
know digmatized by men I think it was
just back then
women knew the consequences of having
sex with someone that's not your husband
do you understand like you can you can
get pregnant and if that person is not
your husband your family will look down
on you and that was the morals back then
like in these Western societies like
that's why women wasn't making those
kind of choices but
when obviously the pill and the
contraceptions and all of that came in
that kind of consequence went away you
understand it kind of went away and when
when when there's no consequence for
anything no matter what it is it can be
it can be anything when there's no
consequence people are going to like
people are gonna like you know go
go all out do you understand people are
going to take it to the most extremes
when there's no concept Madam Walker was
the first female millionaire in the U.S
in the 1800s wow how did she become I
mean what did she do
um an entrepreneur
um philanthropist and social activist
she's the recorded first self-made
millionaire in America madam CJ Walker
real one yeah yeah she sounds like a
boss lady he like broke all the rules
but I don't think she was breaking rules
like again it's just like women had
choices and most women like preferred to
raise kids what's her story and how do
they how how did how did they perceive
her in that era so she
um from what I know she started off she
literally was washing clothes one lady
in the town was a business lady
um she
asked her for how like she did the hair
products and made hair products the lady
wouldn't really help her so madam CJ
Walker like aspired to be like that lady
so what she did is she went back home
and started like trying out new products
testing things and then went out into
like the town trying to sell her product
like she started showing people like the
miracle growth and how it worked from
there uh people just started like
jumping on the bandwagon and then it got
to the point where she
essentially he just built her wealth she
went through a lot of struggles through
it and then became a self-made
millionaire
um but she had Choice it wasn't most
women chose not to do it it was just a
case of choice it wasn't like yes there
were roles but more so it wasn't
yeah you cannot set up a business you
cannot set up your own thing yeah to my
knowledge and this is I think it's that
awareness like obviously that that
exception of a woman she she was aware
of her choices and I think so many
not just women but people go through
life not being aware of their choices or
they're aware of their choices but they
don't know how to no I disagree I just
think at that time they were just very
aware that they were self-actualized
from different things like one of the
biggest aspects of sex uh
self-actualization is to raise the
family as a woman whereas a man it was
to go out there get bread separate
yourself from other men so I think they
were always aware of it but they were
driven by different things like now you
see now in the modern society the higher
achieving woman who sacrifices her
family for a career at best she has one
child she might not even have a fully
functioning relationship you find it
very weird or very very peculiar for a
woman that who makes and let's forget
about the anomaly such as the Kim K's
where you can just make money at a touch
of the bottom let's talk about the
nitty-gritty corporate world you find it
very rare to see a high achieving woman
that has a lot of time for her family
and her predominant goal is to raise the
family it's just not possible well in
general achievement is the exception
most people were poor throughout all of
human history
so any any sort of achievement by anyone
like rich is the exception it's not the
rule
and so and so the fact that like even
few women achieved it like few men
achieved it too
and so I just I don't know how we could
say like that we were held back in any
way
and I think yeah you're right there is
there is that element there
and it's um
I think it's a common theme that runs
runs into our lives even now like how we
like you said about self-actualization
it's it's happened it's even happening
right now like you know people are going
through life and they don't ever
actualize like who they really are they
don't ever question these systems they
don't ever question you know what
systems when I talk about this I'm
talking about like these social ideas
like that women are that women feel
oppressed and are oppressed right it's
like you know it's that it's that belief
in itself that they are like I'm a
person I'm in this situation that closes
people that closes their minds off to
these choices I think you do get those
exceptional people that say well hold on
a minute like
I don't want to I don't want to be like
this I don't want to be like everyone
else and I don't want to I don't want to
follow those rules and I'm gonna follow
follow what rules the social norms of
like in 2022 what's that look like I
would say
like have a family being the mother grow
like be in the house like being staying
at home mom and then like you said like
you think that's this you think that's
the Norms in 2022 I'd say that that's
being challenged oh you're saying but
I'm sorry we're talking about a general
the general idea of what normal is we
know yeah what we generalize is and how
what we measure ourselves against then I
would say I I would disagree I don't
think housewife is typical I don't know
many housewives in general I don't think
the majority of women like really get to
do that
um and in the west and like if that was
true then fifty percent of women hitting
30 wouldn't be single and childless
because they would have had kids by now
most women would fight back against the
idea they have this dangerous idea of I
don't want to depend on the man for
anything yeah so the majority of women
would actually fight back against the
idea of um
of um being a housewife which to me
doesn't really make sense when 80 of
divorces are initiated by women and as
women are naturally hypergamous they get
most of the wealth so what is this fear
of a man controlling the wealth when we
don't live in Saudi Arabia where there's
no divorce laws the divorce or laws are
you take half of the assets so this
whole fear of the man financially
controlling everything is just it's a
fast yeah well this is what I was gonna
sorry go ahead I was gonna say do you
think that's linked to if the guy is
making a lot of money the woman might
feel like she doesn't have a say in life
think it's linked to the baby mother
culture in the US and the UK where a lot
of scorned women have had kids out of
wedlock and the man's [ __ ] off and now
they're scorned from it and they're
teaching that to their daughters when
really
if you had to rationed your pumps and
waited to get a ring on it before
getting [ __ ] raw in the back of an
apartment you wouldn't have this problem
yeah
um well and that's the thing is like in
2022 women are bailed out of every
single bad decision that we make like
every single one we are bailed out so um
for example like they used to require
women to be virgins to get a ring we
make the decision to sleep around and we
still get ranks right that's one bad
decision or let's say we get pregnant
you can get bailed out of that bad
decision because you get an abortion or
you can keep it and you can still give
it up for adoption or you can keep it
and you can still get remarried
typically where like historically that
you would have been done for you even if
you weren't a virgin like you would be
done for and so you have those like
being bailed out of those bad decisions
on top of that woman owned two-thirds of
the Consumer Debt so in all of the
government programs are typically women
on them and they're men paying for them
so it's men always bailing out women for
poor decisions
that's interesting I was actually
talking to my dad about this well I he
kind of blew out because he watched he
watched the podcast and um
you know
one thing that he kind of mentioned was
actually as women we probably have a lot
more like we have
oh because because we're emotional as
beings right it's like the longer term
impact of
these things that can happen and the
consequences of it can have a lot more
of a long-term impact on women than it
can men because obviously women are more
emotional
because what do you what do you mean a
long-term impact as in kind of live life
with you know stress anxiety depression
or you know
um feeling you know carrying that toxic
um behaviors in them or
so I just don't can I have a specific
example of how it would affect men and
women differently okay so let's say for
example
um
a woman has a casual relationship and
then maybe Falls pregnant and then and
then decides to
you know maybe they developed an
emotional attachment with the the the
person but then the man doesn't for
example and then then she becomes
pregnant and then she has to choose
between whether she wants to
you know have a baby or not right so
that that would be like a that would be
an example so but they're long-term
they're potentially because women are
wired and more emotionally the longer
term impact of making that decision and
and actually
going through the consequences of that
of the consequences is more on the woman
no consequences more in wisdom but just
as I'm just saying like as in the action
and reaction like as in the as a result
of the ACT which happened so so the
actors you're talking about sex like
casual sex yeah someone's having casual
sex they fall in love and then the woman
has okay more longer term emotional
impact as a result yeah so let's say
then the father decides that they don't
want to be a part of that child's life
the mother chooses I'm gonna have this
child
um
then she may need that additionals as
you like to call it bailout
um then let's say opposed to men because
that woman's emotional
needs are different well but the thing
is like women are 100 in control of
birth men have no power and no say and
they're on the hook for child support
for 18 years
if they do if if she does have the kid
yeah so how you don't think it's
emotionally impacting someone when they
when they're taking up to in the U.S you
can get up to 50 of a man's income can
you imagine getting two thousand dollars
a month spending a thousand dollars on
your baby mama
you don't think that's I think that does
that can have
an impact on it's like Soul crushing it
can be and that you know I'll be honest
like you know I was I dated someone who
had two two had two children you know
and
I know that you know he went through a
really hard time just trying to be a
part of his children children's lives
you know and that that kind of
that does that does exist but and
obviously he was distressed because of
it but
I would say that
the I would say that it didn't really
emotionally I feel like the emotional
impact would have been a lot more on the
mother
than on the man
because we're instantially more
emotional
so so then what is that if a girls were
emotional wouldn't she not want to kill
the kid
what did killing the kid coming to
because you said we were talking about
that's why they would need the extra
bailout right that's what you're saying
Anthony
[Laughter]
um that is down to whether you believe
abortion is killing a child or not
and that is like subject to Yeah well
yeah I know but the whole the whole
point is like that like women have
rights in that situation and men don't
you see what I'm saying yeah I guess but
then it's
the woman's body
it's the woman's body right but it's
happening to them right the whole point
is it's his wallet right so so in this
case like women are 100 in control of
birth they're not they're not 100 in
control of who gets pregnant but they're
much more in control than men are right
yeah because we have 10 to 15 forms of
birth control yeah that we can use they
have one yeah but then if you think you
like
financially as well like men don't have
to pay if they don't they can go to jail
exactly they'll have the those are
consequence to that but they still have
that choice like they don't have to pay
child but then that's what you're saying
there's a consequence in it and that's
what I was saying earlier you know women
have women yeah there's no consequence
for women do you understand there's no
that I just said no no I just said you
could you can get an abortion if you
want you know you can decide you know to
like adopt the kid give it up for
adoption you like there's so many you
can there's so many pills and and
contraceptions that you can take to
avoid you know these consequences and it
jumps down once the sperm leads the
man's body
that you know he's his life is basically
in your hand and people like to use this
this example of
um
consent to
sex is consent to having a child but
imagine if a man were to do the example
of oh this woman right now at the start
she consented to having sex with me but
I just carried on even though she didn't
want to people be like this guy needs to
get put in prison and you'll get four
years so the whole notion of consent to
sex but the babies come when has he
consented to that I think you consent to
a child as soon as you have sex but it's
like this dilute like you know and I
think but I think we have like where
contraception has given us this freed so
you're saying as soon as you have sexual
consent to a child so that means you can
send to ejaculation so if you if I start
sex with you now you want me to stop
because you've consented to ejaculation
there's nothing you can do to stop me
because you've consented because that's
the same logic
yeah I think you know at the end of the
day if two people are having unprotected
sex then
you're not getting one so what I'm
saying is you're saying is once you
consent to sex you consent to
ejaculation into the other person yeah
we've agreed on that because that's what
causes for a baby to be made yeah yeah
you risk that yeah yeah so if we've
consented to that if you now have sex
with a man and you want to stop he can
now say to you babes you've consented to
ejaculation so you're going to wait here
and you're going to hold every single
inch until I finish because that's what
you consented to is that what you're
advocating for hold every single inch of
what
because you've been sent into the
ejaculation and you run that risk so now
he doesn't want to stop
the same thing no no he doesn't want to
see yeah he doesn't want to stop he
doesn't and you want to stop and he
doesn't want to stop because you've
consented to the risk of ejaculation you
should be able to finish based on that
logic I'm not advocate for this same
based on that logic I can't lie I feel
like that's a moral effect right there
because but based on that logic that's
that logic yeah but it's the same logic
yeah
because you might like because by this
logic then like it's the same thing with
pregnancy like he consented Dev sax he
didn't consent to pregnancy
but that's the but then how uh I don't
understand uh I don't but that's why
we've got contraception that's why we've
got contraception isn't it well what I'm
saying is that at that time should it be
grape if if um if a girl says she's on
birth control and she's not
oh
should that be great oh great because he
consented to or let's let's say an IUD
girl says she is an IUD yeah surely he
consented to sex with the IUD let's say
she doesn't have one should that be
great yeah surely that's equivalent to
stealthy because there you know there's
some laws in the U.S that they're saying
um if a guy takes off the condom that's
great yeah we call that Stealth In Here
British term yeah I think if you're if
you're Chooser if two people are
choosing to have unprotected sex
okay
I also have potentially have that
consequence well it also depends if
you're having casual sex or if you're in
a if you're dating and or if you're in a
relationship I think with casual sex you
need to know you both need to know what
you're dealing with and you know um if
it's just not having casual then you're
going to be using you're both should be
using something I also think as well
that you need to communicate if you're
dating someone you're saying right I
don't want to have kids right now I just
want to well I'm saying if she lies so
if she if she said because there's a lot
of girls that want to trap guys yeah
right if he's If he's big enough yeah
yeah so if a girl lies to him and he
gives consent for sex with an IUD and
she doesn't have one should that be
grape
and the same thing with a condom If he
if she can sense the sex with a condom
and then he takes it off as that grape
I think they both were if one I think
taking taking it off when you're in the
middle of it can only be seen as grape
but equivocally if a woman lies the only
problem is obviously in the eyes of the
law how do you prove that she lied but I
think it should be
I think good great when you look at
grape grape is
an unconsent of that act right and that
like when you're taking if you're if a
woman's gonna say to a man oh yeah I'm
on birth control but she's not and then
she ends up having his baby
like
that's very treatment that's true that's
manipulative yeah that's that's a great
thing that's just a woman being like a
bad person that's a great baby
it's a great baby you stole his semen
so so do you would you say the same
thing then for a woman I forgot it takes
off the condom is it the same
well if there was they would say if the
woman if the woman consents to sex with
a condom man's not feeling it he takes
it off is that grape
I don't think he's great because she's
consented to the actives okay
okay it's consistent that's that's right
yeah what about you guys so you would
say that would be great for both or we
could say essay instead if you want to
make it a lesser that's one thing I
would say I do think it's mad that for
taking it off and obviously I'm not a
lawyer you can get the same as jumping a
woman in the street and dragging into is
that here
um yeah you get the same you get four
years either way shut up if he takes off
a condom yeah you get four years shut up
so it's like I find it's mad that you
can get four years for that but then you
can just pick a random going at the same
time I only I heard that they might have
introduced that in California but I did
not know that was a lot no not here if
you do that they prove it you're going
to prison for four years but there's no
I bet there's no law for the equivalent
which is a woman saying she's iron no no
no no no you D or even stealing a condom
no nothing
because you you guys heard about that
like the NBA issued statement saying
that like the um players need to flush
their condoms because girls were
stealing them wow oh wow I didn't know
that wow yeah they were so prep I mean
think about that's the number one way
NBA players go broke they get the wrong
girl pregnant and that's what I'm saying
it's another thing like it's another
Fail-Safe for a woman's bad decisions
because you picked the wrong guy and now
you get paid for it and there's women
out there and there's pay for it yeah
and there's and there's some women that
don't like do that right like I'm not
saying every single girl like like takes
part in child support but like like at
the end of the day it's another
Fail-Safe for women's bad decisions and
that's why it's almost like we're
children because we get bailed out of
every bad decision that we make we sleep
around
[ __ ] shaming we get fat fat phobia
and there's no there's no equivalence of
these for men then if we sleep around
and get pregnant we have abortion as an
option we have adoption as an option
there's bailout for that we get married
and then we get divorced which is you
know bad like bad decision you can get
alimony or child support so it's every
every bad decision that we make we're
always bailed out
I think like you know but some some of
those but not all of them but definitely
some of those bailouts are also bailouts
for
both parties involved which ones both
like the man and the woman like if for
example abortion let's say a couple
don't want to have a child then they're
both by that woman going through that
but it's a hundred percent the woman's
decision because I couldn't because me
and you can like me and you can have sex
and you know
you get pregnant yeah and let's say I
want the baby but you don't want the
baby I have no power whether you get rid
of the baby or not I just have to like
you know tell you that I want the baby
and hope that you keep the baby because
I said but if you in your head said I do
not want this baby there's nothing that
I can actually physically whatever
there's nothing I can do by law there's
nothing that I can actually do to stop
you from getting rid of that baby yeah
that's so true
and then even even like governments pay
out single mothers they don't pay out
single fathers
but don't you think that's something
then there's something wrong with the
system because like I said previously
when I was dead when I was dating a
person who had two kids you know there
were times where he is a good father and
there were times where he would go into
the court like go to court and try and
you know get joint custody of his kids
and it would be so hard yes like that it
would be so difficult almost impossible
and it went on for years and and then
and then you hear and then you do hear
stories of women who go to court and
they do get that favor they do that's
but that's but that's the court system
that we currently have right yeah that's
what I'm saying it's like that's another
way women are bailed out of bad
decisions because they can leave break
up the home and they still get custody
on the chick and and a check any and
even and women owned two-thirds of
Consumer Debt right so we get homeless
what are their women's shelters
there's not really men's shelters like
that I mean there's like one or two but
not not the same way there's women's
shelters that's true I don't even know
what I don't know what the real time
like real-time data is for that in in
the UK If you're a woman and you have a
child out of wedlock and you're homeless
yeah you get Council house so quickly if
you're if you're a single dad they'll
tell you to get a job big man and sort
it out or your kids are going into care
you're not getting Council houses like
that yeah that's but I think that's a
massive flaw and again the system is
it's not a floor in the system because
the system is made for men to work in
order to put into the system and allow
women to cash out of the system so when
people talk about flaws it's not a flaw
it's how the system is going to work and
obviously as as Pearl has been saying
like
women are 80 of the consumer base so
they know it the system knows that if
men are working and putting into the
system the women are going to take the
money out and spend it on these luxuries
that you that women love you know bags
clothes and you know women are very
spontaneous with their spending so and
like when we talk about for example the
welfare state and we talk about General
double standards this is not us as us as
men advocating that the double standards
shouldn't exist our problem is we accept
these double standards like no man who
pays on a first date is bothered unless
you're broke guy and you're a loser and
you probably don't deserve [ __ ] anyway
but most men are not bothered but what
our problem is when a man now comes out
and says cheating for a man and woman is
different or then women just lose the
plot about it and then it becomes a
double standard conversation and that's
why when we talk about this is just that
okay women talk about how there's this
pay Gap but it's is invisible it's just
because men do the harder jobs that get
most of the rewards so it's like women
choose to go to the education system
they're not blocked from going to the
education system most women achieve
better than men pretty much through
every single aspect of Education more
women go to university than men but who
becomes the corporate Bankers who
becomes the lawyers it's the men not the
women it's not because there's a window
there it's very simple with it's it's
versus reward due to harder job you get
paid more of the money do you think
that's because like women are expected
to
when once they have a child to stay at
home look after the child and they they
kind of
they have they have to you know lead a
certain lifestyle in order to support
their family I disagree with that yeah
well I'm just curious I'm just curious
why do we always say have to instead of
get to yeah you ever think about that
because it's a privilege to get to stay
home with your kids yeah definitely the
majority of women don't get to do that
it's like maybe 20 of women get to be
Housewives so unless you're in the top
20 of like hotness looks like whatever
you probably don't get to stay home you
probably have to work yeah so to me if
there's nothing getting in women's way
okay there's nothing stopping them if
they wanted to do it they do it yeah I
can't just be laughing like this day and
age you can choose to do that or not and
also with that like you have
um women
essentially what do you they have it so
if if a woman gets pregnant the man can
take
it's not uh paternity you can take
paternity yeah it's like six it's like
six weeks that if you're at a really
good firm whereas women it's like six to
nine months in the UK so like they're
making caveats to ensure that there's
some form of equality so it doesn't mean
that a woman has to take time off
completely so and I only going on what
you're saying and a lot of
forward-thinking firms now because of
the whole gender neutral lgbtq movement
they've now made are you get maternity
and paternity but it's shed so there's
no it's not like oh the man now only
gets six weeks and a woman only gets six
months it's now shared you get this
amount of holiday
and then you get to pick that between
whoever
I think that's I think that's really
good
okay so we're gonna react to a video
um so pull up the one from the dating
show-ish
um you guys may have seen this clip this
went viral a couple weeks ago
so tell me when the mics are muted-ish
and I'll show them on here
hello hi what's up you're reading
uh yeah I was actually reading
um
I I ship out in a few days so I was just
reading the artist strategy okay
uh yeah so actually I'm a nuclear
physicist for the Navy yeah so I'll do
that in a few in a few days
how about you
I am 27. I look a little young I'm not
that young
yeah
so where do you live
uh so I'm actually in The Woodlands
Texas right now
um right right down there by Houston I'm
about 30 minutes away from Houston so
I'm a little close
nice okay so tell me a little bit about
yourself
um
man where do I start uh
I like uh I like martial arts a lot I
did a bit of Pharmacy uh back when I was
a little bit younger about two three
years ago I got certified at pharmacy
around when I was 17.
um I didn't really do anything with it I
went to University for a while I was
getting like a business degree so I have
a bachelor's in business and then I did
um Pharmacy for a little while for about
three years and then got bored so I was
like ah let's go see what the military
has to offer didn't do anything
um
got my
I did my pie cat about a year ago got a
96 on that it goes up to a 99 got a 96.
they offered me nuclear physics and I
was like why the [ __ ] not so I went
there and
now I ship out in a few days
okay nice well best of luck as you ship
out pineapples
yeah
why
because he literally didn't tell me any
qualities about himself he's just like I
made a 96 on this I did this and I feel
like I did that at first too
but however I need a man with some
personality
you felt that quick you know you didn't
have personality yes I'm really good at
reading people okay
finish
well that's more that's more than women
yeah okay so
so so so so
I think that's the age thing though she
had a you she wouldn't think like that
she definitely doesn't have kids
no yeah yeah that's true right but so
my question is
again that's another like she's acting
like a child because she's putting like
personality and Vibes over the logical
thing which is this guy gonna be a good
husband
um what are your initial reactions when
we go around
um I felt like
um you could see that she wasn't
impressed she looked like she just
it was a bit bored
um and as you said as well I feel like
you could see that she's quite
young-minded and also you could see what
her preference really was just by even
the way she talked and how she looked
um not trying to be judgmental with that
but that's what I got from it
um the guy to me sounded very
intelligent and very had ambition and
you know seemed like a good guy but that
obviously wasn't her her type
I'd say that age comes into it and it
all comes into alpha male in terms of
when we think of an alpha male people
think oh I'm an alpha male but really
it's contextual to the situation she's
in that part of her life she would have
seen him as an alpha male because he'd
be a leader amongst men would be able to
provide if she had kids but they've
actually singled alpha male she's
probably seeing are the guys who are
shutting down the clubs being Mr bravado
and the alpha males for that situation
in the life cycle that she's in and
unfortunately in terms of looking for a
potential mate and potential partner
those guys usually end up in jail and
they don't pay child support so it's
probably not what you want and that's
why it is childlike
um I just thought it was I thought it
was like really interesting how she just
didn't really value his like intellect
she actually didn't value his intellect
she just like and you can't even say
he's like because he was a good looking
guy you know so she didn't even value
his intellect and it just makes me think
like
wow like you know where you know where
is she at in her life to like not value
something like that and actually
how applicable is that to women as in
more yeah yeah and I think that's uh
that's modern women today black because
it's a
it's a thing of
like it's what's being shown that he's
he's the kind of guy you know from what
you see he's obviously very intelligent
he's obviously very ambitious and
whatnot but he won't he wouldn't have
been you know the most popular guy in
school he wouldn't have been you know
one of the you know the top athletes in
school the football player or the rapper
or the com the funny guy do you
understand he would he would have been
that guy in school he would have
probably been one of The Quiet Ones
that's always you know focused on his on
his schoolwork and that and
those are the guys that get no play
yeah and it's shown again in this kind
of video he's she she's obviously
looking for someone you know like a
drake or a future or someone with clout
someone that as you said personality and
that personality is basically code word
for you know clout he's clouded up or
he's he's got some sort of like I don't
know if you look guys watch power
yeah like you know most women are
looking for like a James St Patrick you
know that that guy that yeah you can
probably put on a suit and look you know
nice but he can put a gun to your mouth
as well that's basically what's
personality means you know so for me is
that that's just the Modern Woman
for me do you guys think that men should
date girls that have dated bad boys in
the past because while this is her tune
now I would guess in 10 years it might
be a very different tune
oh it would definitely be a different
tune I think and so then go around
everyone so you can yeah I think it will
definitely be a different shoe for her
because
the war always hits women and the
Wonderwall hits that's when it's like
it's they have an epiphany and it's like
sudden realizations and stuff like that
and then everything that people was
telling them in their past that they
shouldn't be doing or they should be
going for this kind of man it's like all
of those things coming at once Jonathan
is that all those lessons that you
should have learned coming at once so
it's it's and it's a big appeal to
swallow when you hit the wall where it's
all and then it is you know to listen so
I think yeah she is gonna have a
different dream when she's older so
what's your answer to the question sorry
I wish you have a different tune no I
said like do you think men should date
girls that have dated bad boys in the
past men yeah should men date so when
that girl comes back at 32 no yeah no
like because she's been run free man
she's been run through and it's like if
she didn't value you
but she didn't see the value in you and
you know when you was grinding you know
when you was telling her that you're
you're going off to the Navy to to do
this amazing job but she didn't value
then why would you know why would she of
course your value in hindsight everyone
everything is clear in hindsight do you
understand everything is crystal clear
and I say so and for me personally I
would not I would not if I was that guy
I would not I mean he didn't like me
then so why'd you let me know
see I think that you can date women I
kind of think you should date women who
maybe have dated back the like bad did
you say bad boy yeah the bad boy in the
past like because
just because a woman has dated a bad boy
doesn't mean that she's not
a great person or can can fulfill your
needs or commit your expectations and
your partner but then that that's down
to the individual then like I think you
know some women go into a bad
relationship because of other trauma
that they've heard and sometimes being
in that bad relationship and overcoming
it
is them like being in a bad relationship
and then getting out of that it sounds
like excuses though excuses yeah yeah
like like picking the bad boy like like
to guys when you say oh it's because of
my previous trauma like it just sounds
like an excuse
but you could say that about anything
like you could you you know someone
who's scared of the dog could be like oh
you know well my my dad used to lock me
in a Cupboard at night and that was
traumatic for me but like typically we
respect people that don't do that more
yeah they don't give excuses you know
and it's different and it's different
because it's like I don't think women
are taught what their true value is to a
man not as a human that disclaimer not
as a human but your value to a man like
what does a man value in a woman I don't
think any woman knows that but then who
teaches women those values women are
meant to teach women those values the
women that are wives the women that have
been in relationships the women that
understand that oh yeah I've been with a
husband and they and they understand how
their husband thinks and they understand
how to be a wife Jonathan those are the
women that are meant to you it used to
be the mothers do you understand but
obviously everyone's come from a single
parent home nowadays so it's hard to get
that message across so it's it's it
really and truly should be the one wives
and the women that are teaching the
younger women how how men think and how
you know how how to be valued by a man
how you know what what is it that men
value in you as a woman do you
understand it shouldn't be a man's job
to teach a woman you know what I value
in you as well and you should really
kind of know what I value in you as a
woman because I know what you value me
as a man which I'm saying I know exactly
what I have to do in order to keep you
around and to keep you happy do you
understand so it's like how come you
don't know how to keep me happy or you
don't know what to do and it's kind of
like after a certain age it's like how
many bad boys do you have to go through
to get the message so it's like it's
like because when you come back like 10
years later you're taking away the
things that men value which is like
Purity and Youth
I think when when we talk when women go
through trauma
right when we're not going through
trauma they
so but there's something you said about
value right and I'm just thinking but
like where do you where did you even get
that idea of of the fact that women that
you're saying like oh you know women
should know women should be taught and
women shouldn't just know what a man
needs and should just know what a man
was because it's like for me as a guy I
know what a woman wants do you I know
what woman wants Jonathan if I can the
question of can I provide it is a
different question do you understand but
in terms of do I know what they want I
know exactly what they women have been
talking about what they want for a year
four years it's all over it's all over
social media men ain't [ __ ] and they'll
list all the reasons that men aren't
[ __ ] I want six foot six figures six
inches
that's a phrase but like like now Men
start saying things like oh I don't want
fat chicks and women freak out they
don't want to hear it so like we haven't
been listening to them about what they
want like I want I want a girl that
hasn't slept with the whole football
team and then we come back and say
accept me as I am the reverses women
will actually attack you for them for
those views to try tell you that the way
your your thought process as a man is
broken imagine if that broke men started
a community that said death to hypergamy
the problem there is a [ __ ] March the
broke me on March date the man with no
money I'm so tired and I can [ __ ] all
Pockets matters in it
get that trending that sounds that
sounds crazy and narcissistic but women
do it all the time and that's what and
that's what I mean like it's like you
know we we hear it all the time what
women want like do you understand like
the difference is can you provide it and
that's that's where the difference in
the men come because it's only really
and truly the top 20 of men can provide
you every single thing that you want as
a woman and a lot of times like men will
like put up with like every guy makes
exceptions for a girl they like right
but there's a difference between coming
going to man and saying no love me as I
am even though I had this bad boy
plastic accept it you should date
someone like that and saying no I
probably don't deserve you like those
are two different ways to come at it I
think his depends like whether then you
should judge someone by their past or
not the best that's how men judge women
yeah I mean that's that's common sense
the best predictor of future behavior is
past Behavior if a dude cheated on every
single relationship he'd been in you
think he might cheat on me if a dude
picks bad boy bad boy bad boy bad boy
you're gonna think she might leave me
for a bad boy yeah I think yeah
definitely there is that risk of like
repetitive patterns of behavior
especially if like you said someone
hasn't confronted their their trauma
their past trauma and then they're gonna
repeat into behaviors that they've had
in the past right but then I think
I think what's really great especially
like with covid that's happened is that
like on social media and definitely
there's this uprising of people who are
now talking about past trauma healing
mental health
um and everything else there's so much
more awareness of that topic that is
given women opportunity to look at women
and men the opportunity to look at
themselves heal from themselves and
actually detach from their past
experiences especially whether that be
with a bad boy in the past and now they
want to kind of and that's made them
realize what they want in in well it can
make them realize what they want but
they're still less valuable to men like
you are you are of a lower value to men
if you have dated bad boys in the past
and you're probably gonna have to get a
lesser lesser guy than you had in the
past but we're but instead we tell women
you're equally as valuable and it's just
not true I'm interested would you would
you would you date would you would you
see a woman as less value if
for example if they have a like a
history of maybe dating the wrong man
yeah because I think I think women
struggle with this so much because as a
man obviously you can you can confirm to
me as well when you're young and you're
like 16 you got no money you got no
chest you've just you're just you've not
barely hit puberty and the 19 year old
swells up in his little Ford Focus and
grabs your babes and you're told that
bro bro when you get a bit older you can
have a girl like this but for now you
have to deal with what you have to you
have to build yourself up boys don't get
upset with it they're like you know
Israel is the older drug dealer he had
more money took my girl is what it is
but when you say to a woman that in
reverse that your value is decreasing
it's almost like they can't fathom it
like it's an exception to the rule and
it's think of a
it's not that hard to grasp that
when you get older you're just going to
get less attention to think that in your
40s you can get the same caliber of man
that you could at 23. it's not really
that hard to grasp it's like we try to
use nicer words to to say it to say I
think they see it as like attack on the
value of them yeah it's not attacking
the value of them you gotta remember the
sexual Marketplace the dating
Marketplace is like any Capital markets
any form of capitalism the best product
marketed in the best way always gets the
best outcome so the best product in this
case
would be your body marking it might be
what you wear social media the filters
you use and then that's what you're
going to go into attract the most
interest when you're in your 40s 50s no
matter how much you Market a dead
product when the breast ain't breasted
and it's sagging and you can do keep you
uppies with the breasts like well it's
not the same product I'm sorry and we
have to remember I'm sorry men and women
are different men and women are
different they look at things different
we go through life different everything
is different the way you go through life
is completely different the way I go
through life do you understand so it's
like men will look at your path
to see if you qualify for my future
women are looking at a man's future
do you understand like you want to know
that yeah this guy can provide for any
future offerings of offsprings that we
might have this guy can provide for me
you can give me security that's all
future based a man will look at your
past do you understand like who have you
who have you dated like was your hoe
like you know have you been ran through
Jonathan these are all past stuff and
just to see if you qualify for his
future and if you if you obviously in
your past you know you did things in
your past that makes you disqualified
then that's just how the cookie combos
is because remember if you've worked all
this time to attain this and you've made
all the best choices that's why you see
a lot of older man in terms of forget
Beauty from the side a lot of older men
will wife younger women and I'm not
saying [ __ ] stupid ages I'm saying
like 30 to 23 just for the reason of
less
less chance of baggage she's like why
would I grab a 30 year old that if maybe
she's still she's still single she's
been had all these all these boyfriends
that have affected her she might have a
kid when I can just grab someone who's
23 and not have to deal with that that's
not to say he might not meet someone
who's fat who hasn't gone through all
their things and could be amazing but
it's just a way of chances she's like
why go with the stress and headache just
like a lot of women when they pick they
might have an ex-road man who's now
going straight or they can go for the
Investment Bank it's just like you know
what this guy doesn't have a History of
Violence why am I going to bother with
Jerome the road man who's now [ __ ]
some Forex guy that sells stuff on
Instagram when I can just get a solid
investment banker he's just revised his
whole life it's just a way of odds it
just makes sense do you think that
investment banker wouldn't choose then
that obviously her full dating oh well
that kind of goes back to the start
question of should what let's talk about
assess it in two parts should he date
her and will she still find him
attractive because 10 years ago she
thought the bad boys were attractive so
first of all in terms of the attraction
it all comes back to what I'm saying
about alphanus alphanus is a situation
and that's what makes you Alpha so a lot
of people say ma'am will say I'm an
alpha but you're not your Alpha in this
situation you're putting so to give you
an example and this is a bit of a fact
example at roller tomasi uses is that a
lot of you see that that trend of when a
teacher will
lack
leave his wife for like a young 18 year
old woman
and who used his teacher and they say he
groomed out which he did let's he did he
did groomer but in that situation the
reason why he managed to unlock her is
because he controls the classroom
everyone looks up to him he's the
teacher he might be a dweeb in life but
he's the alpha in that classroom and
that's the way she's got to know him so
that's how he's unlocked her brain now
you when you see eventually when she
awakens is when she leaves the classroom
is run off with him and realize he's
just dweeb and no one respected him he
hasn't got money and no one values him
you see what the difference between
going or going with Mr roadman or for
the Americans for Mr Hood guy he's a bad
man then and everyone respects him in
the hood at that age but then when you
get to your 30s it's the guys with the
money it's the highest value status
quite no matter how old you get those
mad values don't diminish from 30 year
old from 30 years old if you're a
millionaire you're a boss for life
you're bossing the old person's arm
you're smoking all the old ladies I'm
saying you're just a boss anywhere so
that's why I think it's a thing of the
attraction will still stay there it's
not a problem but whether you want to
then go deal with a woman that's got the
baggage of a bad guy is a different
thing yeah well and guys know like who
they were in high school so like if a
guy was a dweeb in high school and now
he's worked for 10 years to get to a
certain status and then this girl says
oh I used to date bad boys all the time
or like I had this toxic ax or this this
guy did this or this guy that says
taking no accountability always painting
herself as the victim like one men can
see through [ __ ] because it takes
two to tango and two they also realize
that you would have passed on them
yeah like if they yeah go ahead yeah I I
agree with what you're saying like it in
terms of you know if a woman does go in
like and
is toxic and has a toxic situation she
could definitely carry that through to
her next relationship but
then it's like
that healing has to take place and that
person's got to find peace with their
past and I still think that
well you can find peace but like the
world is Harsh and the dating play like
the dating Marketplace is hard so just
because you've personally found peace
and moved on from that it doesn't mean
that the world's going to give you
understanding so I think maybe let's say
for example you know how we said like
for a woman for a man to kind of accept
a woman she has to kind of tick 80 of
these boxes whereas for women it's 100
right remember that was that was that
yeah yeah well yeah okay close yeah just
keep going yeah so it's like okay so if
a if a woman is able to show that who
she is as a person is meets that
standard of the guy then maybe that
the baggage part of it well yeah but
like we we deal in probabilities not
possibilities so like that's that's
again illustrating my point a little bit
when I say like women are children
because even now you're thinking of like
the possibilities not the probabilities
and it comes to how the male and female
mind is is different a lot of men fall
in or women fall in love of what like
you could be and that's why you see a
lot of women will try to fix a guy
whereas a man will fall in love with the
idea that she won't change so we meet
the 23 year old Baddie and he doesn't
want her to change and he'll just baste
it on all of her past experiences to the
point I've met her now
she's had this kind of pause she's 23
she's sexy and this is how it's going to
be whereas women will fall in love with
the future so that's why the way you're
talking is it's like oh but they can be
they can be they can be that's not how
men think they just think I've looked at
this that's what it is all the mateys
from the football team have run through
her this is long I can't be bothered and
what if she like I'm just out of
curiosity like what if she didn't tell
you and
it was like and you you've got and you
fell in love with her let's say to speak
and you find out
she dated by bad men back in the day all
right depending on the guy depending on
the guy that you know
personally I the guys that I know don't
leave
yeah
because love is a choice you have to
remember that love is a choice you
choose who you love you understand
because you're looking at from a female
point of view because from a female it's
like if we fall in love like well I'll
Overlook the 10 red flags but from a
male point of view they're like cost
benefit
choice in in a man's eyes anyway love is
a choice I chose to love you do you
understand because you showed me like
you showed me you know
you showed me things that I felt like
was valuable so I'm choosing to love you
I'm choosing to you I'm choosing to give
you
um these my my resource basically you
understand if I now found out that you
know you was on only fans or you you've
been ran through like you know you've
basically deceived me so you're so
you're going to ever so let's just put
it into an example right so you're going
to disregard everything that she is as a
as a person that you're feeling in that
moment that experience that you've had
with her and then you'll just be like oh
yeah well because now I know that you've
had a past
that changes my current experience
that's like okay that's like selling a
car for new prices and then later he
finds out the car has a bunch of issues
and he brings it back to the shop yeah
that's the equivalent again this is what
men value they they value youth they
value Purity and they value they value
loyalty and being hot I'll give you an
example
um I was talking to one girl one time
and this was like years ago and
we she ticks everything like we we had
it all good it was going well
um and one of my boys came up to me and
said yo like is she I heard one of the
guys in his friendship group had said
that she had been unfaithful and at that
moment I just went no I'm out you just
feel disgusted it was it was literally
like that it wasn't even a case if I
wanted to know I had a conversation with
her but I didn't even tell her what
actually happened and I said look I
don't think this is going to work out
um how long was you dating her Force so
three four months
but Pearl in in the UK we call it crb or
DBS checks
I don't know what you call them in the
US but it's basically like it's like a
it's like a play on words or what you do
a criminal background check so you just
say to the man them like oh
put the feeler out I like this girl like
what do you know about it she's from
here ask the man from over there and
then sometimes you get bad reports here
just like
could have been so much it could have
been so much man
but there are sometimes cases where guys
don't want you to leave the pack and
they'll they will say stuff about the
girl
but that's why you have to and that's
what you have to say to the man them
like you have to say like what's the
Intel Source because some guys will say
oh she's a slag because she slept with
two guys but that might just be two guys
from the same area they're from like
what'd you expect I think when you come
with age as well it's almost like when
someone says like oh she's been run
through that all right she's had a
one-night stand like coming bro like
grow up like [ __ ] happens in it it's
more like we do talk of run through uh
he went to that meeting and then she was
in a room and then she was getting the
car keyed and then just like [ __ ] you
know
do you think like someone being like run
through is different to someone who
dates a bad boy
yeah definitely it's like levels levels
of risks yeah bad boy just might mean
you make bad choices where is if you're
promiscuous then the way men see it is
that if you're overly Primary School
it's not that you've had one night
standing you have knee yet you had sex
for months or saying like you're overly
promiscuous so either you've got daddy
issues or you've got Unfaithful issues
in the sense of you are a struggle to be
satisfied with one choice that's
problematic
especially when when 50 of marriages
break down and Men financially lose out
that's like putting half of your wealth
and saying on red or black 50 50 you
need to narrow it down by by risk well
and that's why I've been like another
reason they value youth is because they
want to know if you didn't get married
when you had the most value like what's
wrong with you basically like why why
were you not able to lock that down
[Music]
but nowadays I kind of look at it and go
most women have been misled so they
believe that getting the career yeah the
job is the be all and end all and they
they will get married later so they
haven't understood that their Prime was
at a certain age and so when they get to
a certain age you have the conversation
with them and there's really nothing
wrong with them that it doesn't make any
sense as to why they couldn't lock him
down but then you have a conversation
they're like no no I want to make sure
I'm successful in my career before I
even settle down yeah but I think the
question is like what have they been
doing the last like 10 15 years
that miseducation is feminism yeah as we
know a lot of the institutions they're
very left-wing effeminine feminism is a
large part of that so women scorned
women have taught the younger generation
this is what you need to focus on when
that's why I got even though I my
family's Muslim but I'm not Muslim this
is why I got respect for a lot of the
Islamic Community as soon as they Bus 18
they're looking for husband they're like
I'm not got time to waste I'm trying to
use this in ways with modern Western
culture is more like you know let me
just get [ __ ] out it don't matter and
I'll think about that later but you're
you're losing your Prime
I'm going to take a second
Super Chat
okay guys as you already know
we are trying to get Isha what camera
let's go so Sun super chats we're trying
to get it at the end of this month we're
gonna give him his own you know camera
also our our chat now is members only so
if you want to be a part of the chat
turn on your membership sign up it's
only five bucks a month guys and the
thing is it helps us keep the lights on
here when we have memberships it's a
recurring Revenue views will come and go
so it's really important that we have
memberships and then we can get a bigger
place this next year and just film like
crazy in like a huge ass apartment so
memberships help fund that
um also follow our Facebook page or
twitch page those are new
um
subscribe to the channel if you're
watching stop ghost watching out here
and and then also like the video how
many people we got in the chat right now
we go two thousand four hundred two
thousand four hundred people so guys I
we have never broken 3 000 have we we
broke it once once yes okay so so like
the video because that's the number one
thing you can do I think if we have uh 2
500 people in here we should have at
least have a thousand five hundred likes
so like the video a like is free okay
I'm going to start reading the Super
Chat so
Stefan Pierre Jerome women who date bad
boys are addicted to drama and can't get
that fix from Good Men these women will
cheat or to will cheat to find or create
that fix it's hard for a life of
marriage to compete with years of toxic
drama Chris
cyromancer it's called Uh
hofax in the U.S STFU ffs if I don't
know your history then do I really know
you David Henley men are hit with
reality checks day to day and have to
adjust or be alone women have societal
bulwick of excuses to hide
behind them instead of shaping up Dan
Rich bad boys take what they want good
men require
reciprocation option one is easier for
the ladies STFU ffs if you don't want me
while I'm grinding then I don't you want
you when I'm rolling David Henley from
vid was insane she's looking for a baby
daddy and not a long-term thing this guy
spent more time improv improving himself
than trying to get into chicks Neo Moses
she's a dancer from the W the NBA Hawks
you can see the professional Choice
shows she's looking for The Life Of The
Party The Host saw value I know I saw
value I was like sir
um Half-Life Most states women can hand
a baby to an on-duty hospital staff
member and say you're not coming back
for the baby they are considered safe
havens take a height prediction her
friends are going to lie and tell her
how great of a job she did on the show
STFU ffs consent sex equals consent to
abort abortion hello Vincent Dasa I'll
take a drink every time pull riding girl
on the couch says but we would all be on
the floor blacked out drunk with alcohol
poisoning blackest Panther her body her
choice my body my choice I have to work
for my body for 18 years to risk for 18
years or risk prison what do you have to
say about that Chris Gomez I think women
think that any pushback is oppression
every man gets pushed back from everyone
that they just keep going that was in
the past and now Soca sense they need to
be the need to be right is the need to
be right and the white is amazing
honestly we need guests like her to show
the world the delusion PS anti-equals a
permanent guest oh I'm doing some
reaction videos with Auntie tomorrow so
you guys are going to get more content
with her I know you guys loved her um
Brett Cormier
men have been holding back men have been
holding women back for years men only
gave them the only gave them the vote
all manner of birth control and helped
Autumn oh wait men only gave them the
vote all manners of birth control and
helped domest automate domestic work is
that not enough Melvin cashier with the
with the talk about women believing
their oppression do you think that
there's a lack of want to relearn and
accept depression as a fallback black is
Panther women are not given the choice
outside of domestic settings to protect
them from protect them from themselves
current Society is a perfect example of
what happens as a result STFU ffs what
wmn have more choice to be a 304 if
that's what you want you'll spend your
old age telling your cats how you traded
the family for the good D you got once
Brit Cormier roughly 15 minutes and we
get the women our children because men
are men suppress them historically
almost a new record for bring bringing
up historical suppression without
evidence connecting it to the topic
black is Panther women are not
suppressed they were protected because
they couldn't physically fight back a
man that challenged them Freeman's
Journal women with too many choices are
erratic women make poor decisions re
mating fathers choosing mates for women
are a benefit to women women require
outside structure more like children
black is Panther most women stop
maturing at the at the age they stop
getting male attention they start
getting male attention age 13 and begin
maturing again after the attention stops
after 35
Wes um super chat okay let me
um
refresh because I think there is one or
two more
um okay 90 free toe pay did we make the
green dress lady cry yesterday guys
okay don't stop trying to make my guess
cry this isn't cool this isn't it's not
that what we're trying to do here I will
read your super chats I'm not gonna lie
to you send money please
but but we're not we're not trying to
make people cry okay the UK Economist
does your guest know that due to
feminism women in the UK can now be
drafted in war oh that's a good topic
actually David Henley dude on the left
says do do you understand way too much
um and then that was the one from before
okay I said you'd understand
like you'd understand
do you under oh okay what do you mean by
you don't understand way too much
that that was I I don't know okay so um
next question I have interesting do you
think do you think women should be
drafted in more
um
if I had an army like if I had a country
to protect and like an army I won't drop
no women I think you'd just be inferior
in war like when you look at it
athletically in sports women are worse
at sports that's why they get paid less
but obviously they're better at other
skills such as child bearing and looking
after children so just do that why do
you need to be in the war okay what do
you think
um I think I think no I don't think
women should be I thought I feel like um
there's just some things that men should
just just have for their for themselves
yeah what about you
I think it depends on what is being
asked like what what the task is to be
done the same thing like man would have
to do I think maybe probably I can't
hand-to-hand combat like yeah my hand in
hand carpet would be not because you
wouldn't really
so I think sorry I'm just gonna show
okay okay
um but I think if they can meet the
requirements needed Fitness wise then
possibly but I know that's not really
possible yeah so question this is
something I've been thinking about a lot
lately so
okay
so so
why are you laughing daily go ahead go
ahead so okay okay
historically women right
only got did not get the right to vote
because we did not want to be drafted
right because basically if you vote it
puts some skin in the game right so
because if you vote bad people in the
office we're going to get into a war
then we have to be drafted that's the
consequence
but now we give women in the U.S anyway
the response the freedom of voting but
you take away the consequence
so my argument is if we get to vote I
think we should be equally drafted
and if we're not going to be drafted I
think they shouldn't vote
because you have no skin in the game
that you're putting Lambs out to
slaughter though in it like we know that
I mean we know that women are physically
different to men and it's just like okay
well
go and physically do the same thing even
though we know you're gonna fail at it
like or you're most likely gonna just be
like shot dead straight well I know it's
just like um the freedom which is like
to vote it comes with responsibility and
now you're taking away the
responsibility but giving you the
freedom
because again again so like like okay I
don't know exactly how it works here but
we don't let people like um I forgot
what the term is but there's certain
people that if they're not you like a US
citizen they can't vote because again
they have no skin in the game yeah it's
the same here same yeah if you don't
have a house is it a house it's
something like if you don't have if
you're not registered to address UK
citizen then you can't yeah yeah and so
we're all about equality until it
doesn't benefit us right so so we say
okay that's fine they can they can do
the hard jobs while we take the benefit
but I'm saying if we're going to take
the benefit then shouldn't we equally do
the hard job
but then it's not an equal it's not
equally measured because he said like if
a woman goes oh it's going to be
a lot different but it's women asking
for equality do you understand and it's
like it's like where that is that where
do we cross the line of what's equal and
what's not equal because if if you want
equalities you want equality across the
board or do you want equality and in
certain things and how it looks so far
is that women just want equality in
certain things which is you know you
said Sports earlier get me women want
equality in that Sports you know they
want to be paid you know 350 Grand a
week like Cristiano Ronaldo is and it's
like you like that's not really equal
depends what you mean what it is to be
equal like
for example if you have
and you know you have like I like for
example I used to work at a checkout
right and you'd have a young woman and
an old woman right and let's say the
they're asked to do the same job but
they react like but they're gonna need
different Tools in order to do it
because they're physically different
like once older so she's gonna need more
like assistance as versus the younger
person so I think it's like but we in
order for that to be treated equally
then that additional support needs to be
put in place with an older person
insta to do a similar job that's not a
quality that's Equity okay uh Equity is
you're seeing the likenesses and you're
seeing the differences they are making
adjustments to that but that's not truly
equal because if it was truly equal that
you'd have them doing the same job and
if she wasn't able to do the same job
you just pay less because she's not up
to the job
that would be true equality
but then if you can have someone do a
similar job but with different different
tools for it or a different means of
doing the job
than this but that's not truly equal
because you're given assistance which
costs money but it's like what is
equality is is equal giving equal
opportunity yeah equal opportunity yeah
so so women would have equal opportunity
it doesn't guarantee equal outcomes but
I'm saying if we're if we're taking
because again this is what feminism does
we want all the benefits and we don't
want any of the responsibility we still
want it always to fall on men which it
goes back to even even with the vote men
still bail us out because we we elect
some crazy person into office it's not
us going out to do that [ __ ] that's a
man
so that's why I say like again modern
women are children because we're always
bailed out of everything
I think how can you but how can these
women being bailed out of everything as
a measure for them being children that's
what I know how because when a kid makes
a bad decision well who bails them out
their parents
typically
and so it's like the same concept
but who's the parents in this the man
okay because the men are the men are
always bailing women out of their bad
decisions
that is I think like going back to what
we were like just saying earlier is
about
you know what are the longer longer term
implications and it may be different for
women versus men like we're like I agree
like us women and men are wired
differently and I think you know I don't
I'm not like I don't I don't I'm not
overly well read in feminism but for my
like from my perspective of what
feminism is and it's it just brings
light to those what I said earlier about
the systems yeah but I feel you talk
about the long-term effects but yeah
there's no welfare state
to support sexually deprived men and I
know we're gonna we're gonna laugh at
and say it's funny whatever but the
reason why I talk about this is the
Harvard Business School released the
research paper they talked about
um monogamy is for the benefit of women
and four men for the reason of that in
societies where polygamy is
um promoted leads to younger marriages
control of sex more grapes because
there's less available and there's no
Support classes to help men with the
long-term effects of getting deprivation
because only 20 of the average
population gets play most of the 80
don't get it but there's no support
groups for that like there's nothing
there to just to bail men out of that
and sexual deprivation is one of the
biggest problems when it when it comes
to these offenses and it comes to men's
mental health and how a man will see
himself because he's not able to attract
a woman there's nothing and that's the
majority of men but nothing is there to
help them there's not really anything
there as a safety net and if you want to
talk about the long-term implications
sexual deprivation for your whole life
is is going to be long for anyone man or
woman
you have a
but some there's but that's again I
don't want to go back to the argument
with everyone but
like not not all men are looking to have
sexual lives and sexual activity
obviously I'd beg to differ
like I don't know you know
I want you to ask any man maybe maybe
this may be all right the corn industry
doesn't tell you that that's true yeah
strip clubs sorry strip clubs the whole
sex industry is more or less funded by
men that's why men love corn so much
because yeah it gives you endless
variety to access of women because men
just want to sew their seed so they can
live that fantasy yeah
hmm right
right okay
and remember with um with corn as well
like like you know as you said variety
like
Mendo that men don't usually watch the
same corn episode twice I'm saying it's
usually it's different it's different
they want variety how do you know you
know I've been there but
well if it was it but it's not like
it's because it's because they want
variety and it's not available so you
have to get outside like me personally I
think I think yeah
don't get me don't get it wrong
depression is a serious subject but I
think with men yeah a lot of men here
would not be depressed if they have
money and girls 100 now a lot of men
would not talk about any sort of
depression if they had money and girls
that's it that's all they need and then
there's no such thing as depression no I
think the majority of guys that are in
depression like I believe in PTSD I
believe Peter T is real but in terms of
like depression like
you made some money that depression
you're happy again if you made more
money it's even better now you're
getting girls I don't think there's
there's a lot of depression there
anymore that's just me personally one go
ahead I was just wondering like wonder
what the difference in the depression
rates between men and women right now
men have higher suicide rates
that's why men's mental health week is
all centered around that and even what
you're talking about money
um economists sociologists have repeated
this experiment
over and over that happiness
um I think seventy thousand dollars
um I'm relative to that we need to
factor in inflation and cost of living
in other countries is directly linked to
happiness once you go beyond that level
money is no longer linked to happiness
but before that that is and because
women are hypergamous you have a fell
safe in the sense of just by the way the
world is you might meet someone that
might provide that for you the majority
of women
and Jordan Peterson talks about this
because women are so are hypergamouses
think are that a woman would bail a man
out these high achieving women just
carry on going for high achieving men so
these men are bottom of the barrel you
you have to rely on yourself to get
yourself to that happiness level in
terms of the monetary value whereas a
woman you can be bailed out
do you think women should be bailed out
um yeah I think if
so out of out of the things we talked
about today what what would you say
women should and shouldn't be bailed out
for so so are you talking about
um so which which aspects so we talked
about a lot of we talked about child
support we talked about
um we've talked about voting in the
draft we talked about
um abortion so basically of all the
things that like women are bailed out
for
I think no fault divorce button I think
one should be
um
the child support based on this one
aspect is at the time the child is born
the man signs a piece of paper to
consent to that child so that way it's
fair in a sense of
if it does break down and say he's the
one to initiate the initiate the divorce
she's not out of pocket because by she's
had to sacrifice her career and by no
way that's not her fault the man has
left and left her with having to
sacrifice her career and essentially no
money then I think under those
conditions and yeah she should be
provided support
what about you guys
um yes I am I agree what you said as
well um under those circumstances
um with regards to
um
abortion I feel like there are many
contraceptions and that you can take
there's one and after pill there's all
these other pills
um and there's ways to protect yourself
so I do feel like women should be
accountable for for that as well
especially if um
in this day and age
um so yeah I think some things and
something's not um
yeah what was the original oh so I'm
asking what do you think women should be
bailed out for and what do you think
they should not be bailed out for okay
yeah I think women should be bailed out
for things that are going to have an
impact maybe on their mental health or
is going to have like a on their mental
health just like in general yeah just
that they're meant like even like
they're well their General well-being
right I think but I think but but I
believe
I believe everyone obviously should have
access because I'm all about everyone I
love everyone yeah people uh yeah but
you know everyone should have access to
resources that can support them in
improving so so you think if I choose
not to work as a woman and I rely on
like the men's handouts you think I
should be bailed out for that decision
because working makes me have mental
health issues
that's it I think of it that's actually
a really interesting question you know
because
you know maybe I'm just not made to work
I I shouldn't well I think you know but
it's but there there is that a case
right where women there's women out
there that work and it affects their
mental health right they can't they
can't they can't cope with work or they
can't cope with a lot of things in life
okay so your answer would be yes we
should bail them out I think we should
support people who need support okay so
if I chose not to work because it
affected my mental health I should be
bailed out for that decision by men
yeah don't you think that's a bit
entitled
I think yeah it is entitled when I'm
entitled yeah but you've got bearing in
mind I know you're you're obviously
coming to saying okay well women should
be bowed up I mean but obviously I'm
saying that I think that anyone in who
who who who is struggling with life
um struggling with their well-being
struggling with their health should be
given that support including men and
it's and it's a shame as well that was
we're talking that it's like
you've even like even the men here are
confirming that those Services don't
exist for them you know
um
well but the problem is because you can
only have so many handout programs so
it's like my dad would always explain
you like put two dollars into something
you you take one dollar out like like
even okay I make money in this business
off of like super Chats on the show
sometimes I lose money on these shows
right but I make money in other areas to
make up for it so like when you're
talking about like free government
handouts you can only have so many
people on government dependency and so
like you saw that during the pandemic
there's a lot of people that were paid
not to work and so you can't pay
everyone not to work no you can't
because then that would just have a
right right so how how would you like
navigate that because if you're paying
people not to work more people aren't
going to work yeah yeah
no I I totally get that and I think
you know by supporting people and
helping them so they can get into a
mentality where they can work that would
obviously be well what about the people
that just don't want to
because like I I because I don't have
that now though don't we right we do and
that's what I'm saying like most of the
uh all the hard-working like people I
know like why do they have to pay for
the people that just choose to do
nothing because they're mentally
unstable
I think that's just because they're
mentally I say because we want every
because I think as a society we want
people to have a contribution right
solution make one and get a job wouldn't
you agree like shouldn't they shouldn't
they make a contribution by getting a
job I think they I think that we should
be putting people we should be
supporting people so that they can get a
job right but I'm saying like the people
that don't want to work because it
affects their Mental Health
it also depends on the type of mental
health yeah yeah I feel like if you are
someone that is having panic attacks
anxiety
um you know there are jobs that we that
you can tell they can support you
through your your job but then again
what it depends on what type of jobs
that they can go for if as you said
about the someone I just saying you know
I don't feel like working I'm just I
want to find somebody to look after me I
think usually those types of women
sometimes they go for a certain guy or
they position themselves
um I would say sometimes
um especially on Instagram they will
position themselves where they're going
to find that type of person that can
look after them or just tag along with
them and just get treated but I'm asking
how you would navigate that like how
would you know who just doesn't want to
work because they don't feel like it
I think you would know by just knowing
what what meant what is the actual
mental health that they've got right but
I'm saying like at a policy perspective
anyone can say I have mental health
issues let me not work like I mean in
the pandemic I saw it firsthand in the
U.S like they gave out so much free [ __ ]
that like I know people that quit their
jobs
to gain that that life I think the pan
yeah I definitely think the pandemic did
people got used to being at home do you
know what I mean especially it was they
were paying more than some of their jobs
like like they're literally getting paid
to like do nothing yeah and then that
also now showed people oh I can sit down
and not do nothing can get money it's
it's I don't know how you can
distinguish it though it is it yeah yeah
so that's what I was asking if you knew
how you would distinguish that
like from a policy perspective it's okay
if you don't know no I don't yeah like I
think yeah obviously that would that
would need to be worked out like I don't
think it's possible if I'm being real I
just don't think it's possible to
distinguish you is essentially putting
it out there because you know it's a
problem and there's a need for it
however you're looking at people
essentially to just trust people to do
it and people will manipulate the system
and I think that's the problem with the
left they don't actually look on the
knock-on effect and anything to do with
uh economy There's an opportunity cost
when you do something it's going to
affect someone in a in another way so
when you look at say Martin Luther King
the fact that he marched for everyone to
have the ability to have the Liberty to
get a job that meant more white people
didn't get jobs because more black
people were working so the same way a
lot of people were complaining about
um they wanted the furlough scheme to
put money in their pockets but now we
have this uh cost of living crisis where
inflation is Sky High globally and now
people are suffering below the poverty
line if we just had not done the
furlough situation we would not be in a
situation we're in now but everyone was
calling for at the time and that's why
there's no consequential thinking when
it comes to lefties and they think of we
live in this Airy Fairy Land
unfortunately the world is hard so if we
pick one policy it's gonna it's gonna
hurt some people and that's what it is
and the question is what percentage of
your paycheck would you be willing to
give up for that policy
okay so like would you be willing to
give up 50 of your paycheck
what does it helps to create Services
yeah so like so like let's say you take
home let's just say you take home two
thousand dollars in a month yeah would
you be willing to give up a thousand a
month
I think it depends yes or no if I could
survive
no let's say you can't I can't so so
whatever your bills are now whatever my
bills are now even if you could survive
you wouldn't do that yeah you wouldn't
but obviously I work in Investment
Management I work with rich people every
day you just would not do that if you've
worked from the ground up to get 20
million that year and the government
will say we're just going to get it to
get take 10 million to give it from
[ __ ] Betty from Billy Ricky who's
been breeding up everywhere it don't
make [ __ ] sense like I used to and I
have respected because I used to think
like you but then when I got to a
certain pay packet now any money I now
additionally earn 40 goes to number
government 10 goes to the student loan
do you know how mad that is I lose 50 of
my money when I get a pay ride say I get
10 grand pay rise like it's 5K well and
it keeps you it keeps people in the
middle class that's the other thing
because how are you gonna how are you
gonna move up income brackets if you get
taxed more at every income bracket and I
think a lot of times like that's
especially as women like we always think
someone else is going to pay for that
decision so we'll say oh include
everybody but man it's more like like
they know they're the ones that are
going to be paying for it um
that's kind of true like you know when I
when I think about
when I think about my home life as well
like my dad is the man like he's he's
the man that's the main Breadwinner in
the family and he pays for like he pays
for you know things that we need as in
the household as women so
um
but yeah
um I lost my trailer for a second there
but yeah what do you think that woman
should be bailed out for
um
I kind of I kind of uh I kind of agree
with Bailey on um
on the whole
to be honest I don't know I don't know
I don't know I couldn't think I couldn't
think but I was kind of agreeing with
you when you was talking but um
it all like I don't know what they
should be bailed out of especially when
it comes to mental health I mean
disability I can agree you know if
they've got some sort of disability then
yes maybe you could be bailed out for
not working
um
like if if they're like elderly here
okay maybe maybe but in terms of like
your your eight your full body able and
you know you've got a brain you can
think for yourself and if you actually
try you probably could there I don't
think there's anything that you know you
know what it comes down to and my dad
used to say this actually oh he's just a
mad African Niger man yeah but used to
say to me that mental health is a
privilege right and when I thought that
I used to think that's mad I used to
think because I used to be proper left
field I used to be like I see myself as
a black conservative now in certain
aspects but I think Ah that's so crazy
how could you ever say that but then I
realized
to say that you're depressed and you
can't work because you look in the
mirror and you feel fat and your body
dysmorphia that is a privilege in itself
that's not me to say there's not PTSD
from whether you've been touched as a
kid or whether you've seen gang
shootings or whatever but a lot of the
mental health that we see today is a
privilege like if you were this in other
countries it wouldn't even be part of
you'd be thinking of survival let alone
what do I look like in the mirror I
wasn't good enough to get that job now
I'm going to top myself my love is a
privilege even people that say they're
poor today you're richer than most
people were ever in human history in
terms of standard of living like I'm
from Congo and um in Congo like a lot of
people everyone works do you understand
and a lot of people make less than
less than three grand a year so it's
like that's that's that's probably less
than so EP a date I don't know the maths
but like
there's no that I've I've never heard of
depression or anything like that coming
from people that have come from there
Jonathan of oh I've always heard it here
I've always heard it here and it's like
and it's and it's yeah it's like it's
not like your your legs broken or
something like that something tangible
and something that we can be at RK call
your elderly or something like that
those are tangible things like but it's
like depression and you're just sitting
at home have you heard of anorexia in
Congo
no
you see any obese people there no I mean
there are some fat people who don't get
twisted they saw fat people in Congo but
obesity that's a no I believe that also
the system has made with mental health
that there's there's perk shall I say do
you see what I mean so now you get you
get a car every three years you get you
get money you get house you get a ground
floor you know like there's just they've
made it in a way where it looks good
over there and that's why I do feel like
sometimes people there are genuine
people experiencing mental health and
then there's the ones that they like
yeah I don't have to work because I'd
rather pay council tax I don't have to
do this I have to do that you know what
I mean and some of it they can't fathom
that's normal human emotional the one
that I love
the general people that have dyslexia I
have this graphic I was learning
technical learning disability but I hate
to call that but whatever it is what is
but then there's some you know that kid
he's just a [ __ ] idiot he's just
stupid he's got an IQ like of a
grapefruit but they would just say he's
dyslexic because they can't family is
that that dumb whereas sometimes people
just have low enough talent and they'll
just incentivize it they're like oh he
almost is
can't be this so we need to give him
some kind of diagnosis yeah that's
that's what we're in we're in an era
where everything's a label now you need
to have a label and then it's tick boxes
and then it's do you see what I mean so
I I do think it's a bit of um system how
we how they've portrayed it especially
the last 10 years having a mental health
now you get excusive and jail time you
get what I mean you get off a jail time
there's one guy from my uni he got
caught with
um two ounces of weed he was they were
gonna Nick him and he was gonna get
kicked off the course he brought up all
his doctor's notes saying oh I'm going
through a mental health episode but he
only got the mental health episode
because he wanted extra time to do his
dissertation so he got extra time with
his dissertation because he claimed
mental health then he got nicked and
then he then used that and then he got
his degree do you think people I always
think about like people 100 years ago
would laugh at the issues that we have
today yeah because they're just tougher
yeah and it's not like it's not like
people are different it's just the
society like there's always fail-safes
for bad decisions
it's like one time I was looking at
myself I wouldn't say I was depressed
but one time because I play Semi-Pro
rugby now I was all in the academy
system with a Pro Club I got to 19 they
said I was you wasn't good enough I got
released
I was so sad like at that point of my
time I was so sad but then when I look
back I'm like I just looked at myself
I'm like to feel like your life has
ended and to be feel so sad about that
that is so pathetic it's actually so
pathetic what happened to me yeah I know
exactly
you think you put your whole life into
that when you're not good enough yeah
and you're like that's actually like
there's so much to laugh it's actually
prophetic yeah but I think it's
important to distinguish as well the
different types of mental health because
for example
um you've got people that I've gone
through you know great people that have
gone through
um you know child trauma like hasn't
been touched or something or incest and
stuff like that and I believe that those
they will actually
have problems in other ways so this is
where it is tricky because as they get
older they might develop um depression
because of that what they experiences
when they were younger so again it does
it does the math it does
it's about the level of of of of of the
of the tool mod of the level of the of
the um depression or the mental health
do you see what I mean like for example
not saying that anorexia is not it's a
the class as mental health but also it's
to do with a mind and eating and there's
so much layers to it it's distinguishing
what's worse and what's not and that's
the that's the issue I think the
question is what is the solution with
people like that like because like the
mental health issues aren't going to go
away but it it's almost like if you keep
bailing them out and allowing them to
make bad decisions is that is that
better in the long term for them
yeah it's it's now that they give their
medication or they give therapy and
things do you know what's crazy there is
have you did you see that interview of
that girl that escaped North Korea and
she was on like Joe Rogan yeah and then
talking about how Americans she's like
Mental Health
the girl that like escaped North Korea
and then they're explaining therapy to
her and she's like what why would I need
to do therapy she's like I'm gonna talk
to someone about my problem
she's like how would that fix just kill
him of Life yeah yeah and that's the I
think privilege is blind to the people
that have it in it yeah so it's like
obviously we live in a society where
it's developed and everything is that
you know a lot of fingertips basically
so and it's like you know when you're
when you're in that kind of situation
you don't really see the real world and
it's like
people like people from North Korea or
people from Congo or anywhere in Africa
you can name or anywhere in South
America like it's like like those people
go through that real life stuff and then
I think someone said it the more poor
the country is the more you know aligned
it is with like gender roles and stuff
like that where women understand that
you're the men are the men and we are
the women I think one privilege and
development and deciding that we live in
everyone becomes so comfortable
everyone becomes so comfortable that
they forget you know where they come
from kind of thing you forget where
you've come from and you know it does
that saying in it when you get rich and
you forget where you come from you've
kind of lost yourself and and that's
kind of like the society that we're
living in here in it you know everyone's
so comfortable that we've forgotten
where we come from and it's like there's
excuses for everything you know like
depression and mental health and whatnot
and like part of me kind of like
understands it do you understand like as
you said like you know if you've seen
shootings when you were young or as a
little girl you got you got like you
know touched by your uncle or whatever
Jonathan like those are kind of real
things that I can understand I couldn't
be like all right cool I can emphasizing
you know a bit of understanding but it's
like
work
like getting up getting up and going to
work or you don't feel like it today
because you just don't feel like I think
that's just excuses and I think like you
know and it's and it's the result of the
fact that everyone's become so
comfortable Jonathan because if he was
in Africa it doesn't matter if you're
sick
it doesn't matter you're getting up and
you're carrying that big bowl of water
on your head in the town and walk in
five miles do you understand and and
there's no excuses otherwise you don't
eat forget me but when you're in these
kind of societies is it's simple isn't
it and even that girl she was like yeah
everyone there they said
they were crying about their boyfriends
and she's like I escaped North Korea
what are you guys even crying about
but do you think that also because the
hardship and struggle it's like you're
in in in when we're in the UK is you've
got Choice that's do you think that's
what it is yeah I think back home if
they had choice they would
back home
but I think back home like people want
to work
people want to work it's too hot to like
just sit around and you know you have to
do something can it you have to do
something and because the majority of
the population is poor anyway like
people have to work you know then you
have to do something for you for your
children to eat for for you to eat for
your family to eat and obviously that
always falls on like you know the men
especially the only thing you have to go
out there and make you know maybe your
wife will go to the market and probably
sell some sugar do you get me but you
have to bring in something so that
everybody can eat to get me and and
that's that's the only choice you kind
of got that's what I'm saying if they
had these these privileges in the in
those countries you think
there would be a bit more like you know
listen Maybe maybe over time maybe over
time because I think that's that happens
to nearly every Empire like every every
kind of like when they get to you know
good too big for their boots it's like
it gets corrupt from the inside and I
think that's what's kind of happening
and this Society it's like becoming
corrupt from the inside yeah you know
the men are against the women whites
against the blacks the lgbtq against
everybody else and I think too much
choice is a psychological mind [ __ ]
because what happens is when someone has
so much Choice the two to three options
that they once had now they've got more
it makes it more difficult to make a
decision and then also they are now
making decisions based on facts that
they didn't have in mind when they had
the
one option or the second option I have a
question do you think fat people should
get food stamps because clearly they
have enough food
like I'm done
you clearly have enough like
um people still need to eat don't they
not that much not that much like clearly
they need to eat less if you're fat yeah
I think you should get food stamps but I
think it should be like they should
control it like oh oatmeal and broccoli
but like you're clearly eating enough
our food stamps are limited though
aren't you like given I don't know I
don't know how it works I'm just saying
like if you're going to the government
right and you're saying I want you to
pay for my food because I don't have
enough food and then your results is
your fat it's like well you clearly have
enough food sometimes like people some
I'm not saying if it were some people
are fat because they don't know how to
eat like I
I was like really really overweight once
and I think it's purely because I didn't
really know how to eat but you were
eating too much food I was eating way
too much yeah yeah so like
I was eating yeah yeah I've been fat and
I was eating too much food well one
caveat I think I think for the UK it
works but for certain countries like um
what I've heard in Mexico uh the reason
why a lot of them are obese obviously
overeating as well but it's actually
food availability because it's not a
cost effective in those countries so I
heard like um the price of water I
bottled water was double the price of
Coca-Cola so for them it's availability
so but obviously in the UK it doesn't
stand true but I know in countries like
those it's a bit more complex because
they're not actually it's not available
to have fresh fruit yeah but like
you're still eating too much
like at the end of the day if you're fat
you're eating too much you might not be
eating like you could still be thin I
know people that are skinny and they eat
horrible foods but they just don't eat
too much of it
I just have a lot of few cookies yeah
yeah no I know people like I'm sure you
could think of someone top of your head
I remember watching like a YouTube video
Once where there was a like a family
given
food stamps and like they the they were
saying that
you know the the processed crappy food
is cheaper versus like fresh food I
don't know how true that is now eggs
oatmeal and eggs
like I'm saying that's that's cheap you
can get a whole cart in a bag yeah
that's super good for you yeah okay I'm
gonna Read Super Chat
um and then oh no where's the
oh no hold on I thought I was gonna Read
Super Chat sorry guys
um okay guys while I'm loading this like
the video okay for real I'm so tired of
you guys ninja watching there's over 2
000 of you in here okay
we should at least have a thousand five
hundred likes by now I don't I don't
know what we're at but it should at
least be don't make me look after this
video and not see a thousand five
hundred likes I'm gonna be salty okay
I'm going to be salty also also
subscribe to the channel okay I'm really
tired
of people the ninja Watchers right I I
see you guys so
also thank you for all the donations
they're going towards getting issue
camera let's go it's also going towards
I'd like to get two cameras at the end
of the month I think I think we're gonna
be able to swing issues but my goal is I
really would like to get two cameras
ended this month so
um Niels please do not speak
disparagingly about depression it's a
real disorder my cousin lost some
executive position because of this
depression um STFU ffs Pearl has a real
bug up her ass about weight 93 Tope ask
white shirt what's your most
controversial opinion what's your most
controversial opinion oh wait wait why
white shirt that's you is that me
okay well you always win both answer
because I don't know who it's talking
about because you're in a shirt but
you're wearing white so
all right what's my most controversial
opinion
I'll let you go first [ __ ] I need to
think of one where I won't get [ __ ]
canceled
my most controversial opinion
um
I get what you mean like I'm trying to
choose an opinion it's quiet
opinions can change do it come on do it
do it say it what's in your mind Speak
Your Truth Speak Your Truth Speak Your
Truth nice Matt that's too mad I think
maybe one thing that I think about that
could be deemed as controversial is that
we're leaving a culture where we
like we're like depression like we're
saying depression depression is the
default anxiety is default like I was
diagnosed with anxiety and depression I
went through therapy and it didn't you
know but I felt like actually is when I
learned uh when I learned like there was
a when I had more of it in invasive
approach and had more like a different
life perspective I was able and learned
how to change how I feel and I learned
how to
look at World a different way it helped
me relieve my anxiety depression but I
think we live in this Subway where we
default
where people are labeling themselves of
anxiety depression then they go to the
doctor and then the doctor kind of just
like because I've been through that
system as well they say oh yeah you've
got a depression now how about some and
would you like to take antidepressants
you know that was the first question I
was asked as soon as I walked into a
doctor's and then I think what happens
is this is does not apply to everybody
so I you know but I think then what
happens is people they believe they're
depressed to believe anxious and then
they carry that state of being anxious
and depressed and then they take that as
this is who I am I'm now I'm an anxious
and pressed person and then
they do then they're phased with more
and more like the the situations around
them validate how they feel you know
rather than kind of challenge like
challenging the way that they feel in
their views that they're having about
themselves
um so I think that yeah I think that
some people manifest what would be I
think some people manifest their own
depression and anxiety yeah okay and
yeah okay I can't say my most
controversial ones because currently I'm
employed but when I do content full-time
you can hear them all but for now
I have a selfish one and I believe most
people are idiots and in this world
that's why they don't do well
financially but the knowledge and tools
are out there to make themselves become
educated and to do well
but because we're in a capitalist
Society I'm not in the habit of teaching
everyone so the worse people do the
better I do
that's funny
okay there's clinical depression caused
by a chemical imbalance which is
actually rare and then there's feeling
depressed which is common and stupid
STFU ffs first world girls have first
world entitlement and problems Brandon
airs as a man who came from nothing
worked 80 hours a week for four years
his way out of poverty to now making six
figures at 28 if you want the life if
you want the life your mental health
better be on your lunch break AJ 64.
I have noticed modern women can only
view relationships relationships through
a child's eyes that's because they were
never taught how to be a wife or a mom
this is why women refer to the duties of
a wife like that of a mom all things new
why are Anti-Federalists so also
oppression racism deniers 90 free Tope
women can spot a beta but never an
abusive man weird STFU ffs she doesn't
seem to understand English when she's
wrong K to the Swiss yes in response to
the title All Things New oppression is a
thing pearly stop minimizing dub man I
agree with the lady in the corner I have
panic attack every attacks every time I
pay my bills nobody should have to go
through this ik though hell
jeria equality of opportunity doesn't
mean accommodating lack of
qualifications or capability so two
different people can have the same
outcome Mr missing 44 bailed out for the
things that affect their mental health
dot dot dot so everything
um
Cyro Manser bailouts have created the
modern women that copied with the lack
of accountability personally I think no
I think only uh bailouts can be a
reality check with a side of
accountability 90 free Tope Pearl why do
you let your females deflect your
questions ask them but before they
answer have them repeat the question
Watch What Happens hip-hop Optimus
thoughts on Ray faino the most prolific
U.S whiner we I'm getting a
presidential medal before Phelps who was
a the most prolific Olympian ever who
got a
metal uh Megan rufina who's that uh
she's a female soccer player so the girl
the short hair with the purple hair yes
that's the one is she sexy or no no no
she's she's okay it's more like she's
just she's the one that's like
complaining about equal pay oh right get
better at sport which no that's what I
say I think that's I'm an athlete it I
I feel so strongly about girls
complaining because they don't get paid
enough sorry we're not as good as men
like that's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard in my life
no one watches take take the L like
that's not fun I wish more people
watched us but like take the L and move
on
you know the Lions they practice right
by here one of the best women's
basketball teams I've ever seen in my
life I've never heard of them yeah
that's that's the point
and I played 12 teen ish years of
basketball and I have never like played
with girls that good like they're
phenomenal no nobody's trying to watch
them
um
sorry if you guys are watching it like
y'all are cool but like it's just is
what it is
um Wes white shirt counts as a child
because she apparently has trouble
understanding simple metaphors she
purposely acts obtuse when she doesn't
agree
David Henley Pearl XX means women oh
that makes so much sense superchat's
limit letter count so brevardi is key
um braverity is counts brevity brevity
oh okay my bad um Brandon a is as long
as women are financially incentivized to
divorce and have unwanted children they
should face the draft men need equal
rights love you Pearl sent Nation what
are your thoughts about feminists and
Swedish Swedish government trying to
sabotage men getting married in Thailand
and bringing them back to Sweden um they
shouldn't do that JC women can be in the
war just not on the front line 93 Tope I
was being sincere sincere she looked
upset I felt bad Senor sticks would any
of these ladies saddle up to a Lil Wayne
Wiz Khalifa future for provisioning as
long as high value then
and for provisioning as as they count as
high value than given guys a chance 90
free Tope oh did we make the girl cry
yesterday I'm gonna refresh it real
quick well I'm did you have something
yeah I'm not super sure he said that
Swedish men are bringing entire women
and marrying them and you said they
shouldn't do that why do you think no no
the government was stopping them I guess
yeah they shouldn't say yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh no no I'm always saying
that they couldn't I said if you could
afford a girl overseas go get one
they're better than us I'm not trying to
yeah we're in the same thing no yeah if
you guys can afford one go get one I
would pick take them over us too um
what cheap as well yeah yeah the UK
Economist looking good today Pearl thank
you dubman
um I don't know what's getting better
for depression when men getting laid and
getting paid because when you're getting
one the other is getting away 90 free
Tope by the way you sing really well
Pearl No Cap no simp thank you simply
too awesome Jordan Peterson did an
excellent video oh no I can't say your
name you know me Park possibly who
escaped North Korea I can't highly
recommend this video enough it's on his
channel do watch yeah that's the video
I'm talking about it definitely was that
girl she she's a badass like that is the
coolest interview
Nails please do not okay I already read
that one so um I think I'm gonna wrap up
the show so thank you guys for coming
why don't we go around you can say any
final thoughts if you guys have any
final thoughts from the audience Super
Chat them now and I'll read them after
they go around
um
yeah uh peace overall you can find me on
Instagram at
psilver.ohg uh I do music
um final thoughts uh privilege is blind
to those that have it me personally I
want Western women to actually become
wives you know like a lot of you a lot
of women
I think you'll it'll be beneficial for
you for the women in the future Jonathan
if you have family you have kids because
when you're fully 50 60 and past it
the guys that are checking you today
they're not going to be checking you so
if you don't have your own family your
own man that you know you can rely on
and you can be around and that could be
your Social Circle if you can have that
I say try get that now in it because
it's a long journey when you're by
yourself
okay so my handle is limitless.ha you
can find me on Instagram I think my
final thoughts are that it's really
great that we're able to bring to light
certain issues in in our society and
looking at and actually explore the gaps
in what we can do to make it better
uh daily one half of the domino effect
podcast we always come on in there and
cause Havoc make sure the link to our
podcast is in the description so make
sure you subscribe to that so you can
hear my voice all the time I mean EDS my
final thoughts are I love what today
covered double standards between men and
women
um most of us most masculine men most
real men have no problem with these
double standards we recognize it is for
what it is so if you're a girl you've
got big breasts and you get in the club
for free we're not mad at that do that
if you're a good looking girl and you
get don't have to pay for dates do that
what we're trying to identify is that
there's double standards between men and
women that benefits us both in different
ways let's not try and fight against it
and try to say that we're the same
right so um you can find me on let's
pattern coaching
and
um final words I will say is
keep communicating and remain positive
and
um
yeah just just keep positive communicate
and keep it real and it's important as
well to just understand that you keep be
a team work together as a team don't
don't go against each other because at
the end of the day Teamwork Makes a
Dream Work
okay guys a couple super chats we got 90
free Tope in France it's illegal for men
to ask for a paternity test that's crazy
blackest Panther girl in the white is
cute not gonna lie she can get wiped if
she learns to talk less and listen more
token E30 depression starts with the
food you eat eat bad food you'll feel
bad music is a reason why people feel
depressed David Henley ish should read
the super chats hey don't start that
the UK Economist I'm looking good today
Pearl um thank you
um okay guys don't forget to like the
video
um on your way out it's really important
that's the first thing that's the most
important in the algorithm is likes on
the video second off sign up for our
memberships it helps keep the lights on
here it helps keep keep everybody
employed it's really important that we
get a base of members on top of that you
guys get two bonus videos and our Vlogs
are fire we are some entertaining people
right-ish
thank you so much for the super chats
today
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and we will
talk to you next time
oh yeah yeah sorry guys my insta's just
stopped pearly things go follow I want
to get to 20 000 on Instagram I think
that'd be cool so I always forget but
yeah follow my Instagram someone amazing
bye yes has been growing quick though
it's like 14